GOOD MORNING THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THEPUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE WITH
NOT EVER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WITH ME ARE
SENATOR CORTESE. SENATOR DOLLY
GLAZER LEYVA MCGUIRE AND PAN.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC AXIS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE RIVERS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE NINE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS FIVE SEVEN ZERO TWO.
THREE EIGHT ZERO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES SOME WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROP WOULD YOU BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATE IT OR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PRESS IS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE AND YOU DID AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AT
THIS IS COST CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTED CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT A HEARING
IN AS CLOSE TO THE MATTER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAYBE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
JUST INTO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE TEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA BY BILLS ARE IN
CONSENT THE B. THE BILLS ON
CONSENT OUR- ITEM FOR AB THREE
FORTY. ITEM SIX AB EIGHT SIXTY
FIVE. ITEM EIGHT AB TEN FIFTY
FIVE. ITEM NINE AB TWELVE
NINETY FOUR ITEM TEN. AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S LIST
I WILL SUPPORT HIM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
LEYVA. LEYVA HERE OCHO ABOVE
HERE THE TROUBLE CARE COURTESY
YOUR ATTENTION HERE DELHI.
DELHI HERE GLAZER GLAZER HERE
MCGUIRE HAND HERE AND HERE THE
COURT. THE CONSULTANT NOTES A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE UP
pTIME CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE SENATOR LEYVA HI LEYVA
AYE OTOBO AYE THE TROUBLED BY
COURTESY. COURTESY I DELI DELI
BY GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
PAN ALL RIGHT AN ONLINE. BUT WE
WILL HOLD THAT ROLE OPEN FOR
OUR MEMBERS WERE ABSENT I'D
LIKE TO THINK MY VICE CHAIR FOR
GETTING US STARTED WHILE I WAS
IN THE SIMPLY AT PRESENT IN THE
BILL WE'RE NOW GOING TO START
WITH OUR FIRST BILL A. B.
NINETY TWO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAAS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THERE PRESENT TO YOU
AB NINETY TWO WHICH WILL CREATE
AN EQUITABLE SLIDING SCALE FOR
FAMILY FEES FOR CHILD CARE AND
WILL ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN ON
WORKING FAMILIES STRUGGLING TO
PAY FOR THE SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE STATES FIRST PICK FOR
PARENTS WHO NEED CHILD CARE
SERVICES. WELL THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF STATE AND FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAMS THAT HELP
FAMILIES PAY FOR CHILD CARE.
FAMILIES WHO NEED CARE MUST
STILL PAY WHAT IS CALLED FAMILY
FEES. THESE FEES GROW AS INCOME
RISES AND CAN BE UP TO FOUR SIX
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE DOLLARS PER
MONTH. WHICH IS NOT AFFORDABLE
FOR MANY WORKING FAMILIES. THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
ONLY HEIGHTENED. THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE
ESPECIALLY FOR WORKING MOTHERS
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR OR A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL
WORKFORCE. AB NINETY TWO WILL
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BY
CONVENING A WORKING GROUP OF
PARENTS PROVIDERS AND CHILD
CARE STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP AN
EQUITABLE SLIDING SCALE FOR
FAMILY FEES IT BETTER REFLECTS
FAMILIES AND BUDGETS. THIS BILL
WILL PROTECT CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BY ENSURING THEY DO
NOT ABSORB THE COST OF A
REDUCTION IN FAMILY TREES AND
THAT THE NUMBER OF CHILD CARE
SLOTS OR SPACES IN CALIFORNIA
IS NOT REDUCED. FINALLY AB
NINETY TWO WILL UTILIZE FEDERAL
FUNDING TO TEMPORARILY WAIVE
FAMILY FEES. FOR ALL FAMILIES
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
REDUCE THE HARDSHIP OF COVERT
NINETEEN ON CALIFORNIANS AND AS
PERMITTED UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
HERE TO TESTIFY IS MAKAYLA MODA
A PARENTS PAYING HIGH FAMILY
FEES FOR HER CHILD CARE AND
LORI FURSTENFELD WITH A CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE WILL GO TO
OUR LEAD SUPPORT MAKAYLA YOU
CAN START ASAP YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GREAT THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH HELLO MY NAME IS
CARLA MARTHA AND I LIVE IN
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA. MY MOTHER
TO A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD. AND I
OBJECT AND A TWO YEAR OLD AND
I'VE JUST COMPLETED TWO MASTERS
DEGREES AS A MARRIAGE FAMILY
THERAPIST AND COOLED BY
COLLEGE. I GRADUATED WITH HIGH
HONORS FROM ST MARY'S COLLEGE
OF CALIFORNIA I'M CENTRAL
WORKER WORKING WITH STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS HAVE WHILE
PROVIDING THERAPEUTIC CHILDREN
SERVICES WITHIN MY COMMUNITY.
IN STROMA BUT YOU WOULDN'T THE
MY VIOLENCE AND PROVIDE ALL
AREAS OF THE BEACH. I'M ALSO
PROUD MEMBER APPARENTLY.
WITHOUT CHILD CARE I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO REACH MY
GOALS AND PROVIDED FINANCIAL
SUPPORT AND SERVICES TO MY
COMMUNITY A QUESTION ABOUT A
MOTHER AT THE END COMMUNITY.
LET ME SHARE WITH YOU MY CHILD
CARE CHILDCARE JOURNEY I WAS ON
THE CHILD CARE WAITING LISTS
FOR OVER A YEAR THERE WERE ONE
THOUSAND CHILDREN I HAVE MY SON
WAITING FOR SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE IN MY COMMUNITY ALONE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS WAITING
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY AS A COMMUNITY MEMBER
YOUR NEIGHBOR I SPOKE LIKE
COLLEGES MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER
AND MY MOST IMPORTANT ROLE AS A
MOM. I ASK THAT YU IMAGINE NOT
BEING ABLE TO PUT YOUR BABY TO
SLEEP BECAUSE YOU HVE TO WORK
NIGHT I'VE BEEN EACH DRIVER TO
PAY YOUR BILL. AFTER OVER A
YEAR WAITING FOR CHILD CARE THE
CARE ACT PROVIDED RELIEF WOULD
BE ESSENTIAL WORKER CHILDCARE
VOUCHERS I WAS ABLE TO QUIT MY
SECOND JOB FOCUS ON SCHOOL AND
GET THOSE NIGHT BACK THE MY
BABY COULD FALL ASLEEP IN MY
ARMS. DURING THAT CRAZY YEAR I
NEEDED HIS HARPER AS MUCH AS
YOU NEED OF MINE ESPECIALLY
WHEN HE CONTRACTED COAL THAT
NINETEEN IN MAY OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD DIAGNOSED
WITH COLON NINETEEN WHEN THE
WORLD AS WE KNEW IT WAS ON
HOLD. AND ALTHOUGH I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THE VOUCHER I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT I WOULD HAVE TO PAY A
FAMILY THE FOR THE SUBSIDY
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
MONTH. SOMEONE MIGHT THINK THAT
THREE HUNDRED IS THERE A LOT TO
PAY FOR CHILD CARE WHAT WE. AND
CREDIT CARD MY HUSBAND AND
ANOTHER CENTRAL WORKER HAVE A
LONG COMMUTE A LOT OF HIS
INCOME GO TO GAS AND SOMETIMES
THE CHAT WELL SHORT PAY HALF OF
THE RENT. I'M CURRENTLY FILLING
OUT FORMS TO GET ADDICTED TO MY
BOUNCE FOR PG&E I'M NOT HEARD
BACK. FROM YOU NEITHER ONE BUT
I'M. KEEPING MY FAITH THAT
SOMETHING WILL COME THROUGH.
BUT MY HUSBAND AND I MAKE ORDER
TO OUR CHILD CARE FAMILY.
IMAGINE HAVING TO REST
ELECTRICITE DE IN ORDER TO PAY
FOR CHILD CARE. IF YOU WERE
ELIMINATED I WOULD USE THE
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
IMMEDIATELY TO CATCH UP ON IN
THIS BILL. AND MAKE ME FEEL
EMBARRASSED. TO BE FELL BEHIND
HEY MICHAEL GOOD CONNECTED TO
HOW I SEE MYSELF AND THE LEVEL
OF MATURITY AND BE RESPONSIBLE.
AND ENDING THE FAMILY B. SHOULD
BE ONGOING NOT JUST FOR ONE
YEAR. MY FAMILY HAS ALSO TRIED
TO CONTACT MY FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDER. WHO IS LIKE FAMILY TO
US THE STATE REDUCES HER
PAYCHECK AND EXPECT MY FAMILY
TO MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE. SHE
SPENT HOURS CLEANING AND
SANITIZING COST YOU CAN AFFORD
I FEEL PRESSURE BECAUSE OF THAT
OKAY MY FAMILY B. I TAKE MONEY
OUT OF. POCKET. AND ABUSING MY
CHILD CARE. WE'RE CALLING ON
OUR OUR OUR ALLY. OF TO PASS A
NINETY TWO TO AND PRACTICE OF.
FOR CHILDCARE ON THE- OF OUR
WORKING FAMILIES ALREADY
STRETCHED THEN I LIKE TO UP
THANK IN SHINE TO SOME MEMBER.
READ WILL BE IN THE CHAMPION
FOR THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OUR FAMILY SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO ASK THEMSELVES DO I
SEE MY FAMILY THEY ARE DIRECTLY
ELECTRICITY. CHILD CARE IS
ESSENTIAL AS HEALTHCARE ENABLES
CHILDREN BATCH OF MY SON
MADISON. BELIED AND BUILD ON
THEIR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SKILLS
AND ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT. CHILD
CARE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
HOME IS THE FOUNDATION OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT AND
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY SKILLS TO
BEABLE TO NAVIGATE AND SUCCEED
IN LIFE. WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
BACK TO THE WAY THINGS WORK WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
OUR CHILD CARE OF AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS. AND BRING EQUITY TO OUR
CHILD CARE SYSTEM IMAGINE A
FUTURE WHERE ALL FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY NO COST CHILD
CARE WITH THE WORK OF CHILD
CARE WILL BE MA'AM. CAN I ASK
YOU TO WRAP UP THE VIEWS ALL OF
YOUR. TIME AND ALL OF THE-
OTHER WITNESSES TIME. OKAY OKAY.
I'M VERY SORRY WE JUST NEED
YOURSELF ON A NINETY TWO SOME
OF THEM CLOSE. OUR CHILDREN
NEED YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE MISS FIRST SYNCED
FIELD IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
SUPPORT THAT BE GREAT. YES GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS LAURIE
FURSTENFELD AND I AM THE CO
DIRECTOR OF LEGAL AND
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY FROM THE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL GO TO SUPPORT AND
ROOM FORTY TWO- OH THREE.
SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ON MY SCREEN I
SEE NO ONE. WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES THERE WE GO
SEEING NO ONE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF AB NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETY
TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETY TWO. PRESS ONE THERE ARE
NOW. MY NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
THIS IS DONNA HOFFMAN CALLING
ON BEHALF CALPERS JOHN AMERICA
READY NATION AND FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. BY NUMBER THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
CHAIRED SUMMIT ON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WILL TURN INTO
PAYMENT PROGRAMS OF STATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
KATHY MOSSBERG WITH THE FIRST
FIVE ASSERTION OF CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETY
TWO THANK YOU. BLIND NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CRISTINA
MARCELLA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AND LYFT
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW AND
BEFORE. LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS NICOLE BORNEMANN ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
AND THE CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI DIANA THE MAIN GUYS WITH
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER IN
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KATHY DONE OFTEN
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. NINETY
TWO. MY NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND FOUNDER AND PROGRAMMER.
ELLIOT CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BLIND NUMBER FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
BILLY MCKAY CALLING ON BEHALF
OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA AND
FIRST FIVE LA IMPORTANCE
MEASURE THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE THREE
THREE WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU IN THE MORNING. AT
THE TIME MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WHICH I HAVE NONE
LISTED WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION
HERE ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING THEN MADAM
MODERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
OPPOSE AB NINETY TWO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINETY TWO.
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETY TWO.
CONTRACTS ONE THAN THEIR OWN
NOW. SENATOR TOM ADAMS HERE WE-HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAM. ALL RIGHT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN. ACTUALLY ASKS FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU ARE WE HAVE
A MOTION BY. SENATOR PAN MA'AM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. A.
B. NINETY TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
SENATOR LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
OCHO ABOVE. A CHOI BOGUE AYE
COURTESY AYE COURTESY AYE
DALLY. GLAZER GLAZER I'D
MCGUIRE. PAN HI AN HIGH. I
BELIEVE THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLYWOMAN RAISE HAVE A
GREAT REST OF THE DAY. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE NOW ON THE FILE
ITEM TWO AB TWO THREE THREE BY
SENATOR EXCUSE ME ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BOERNER HORVATH. AS SOON
AS WE'RE READY FOR YOU PLEASE
BEGAN. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWO
THIRTY THREE SIXTEEN ASSURE
THAT ALL STUDENTS APPLYING THE
UNIT TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE A FAIR SHOT AT
OF ADMISSION REGARDLESS OF
THEIR WEALTH OR FAMILY
CONNECTIONS WHEN YOU SEE CAMPUS
STUFF WERE IMPLICATED IN THE
FBI'S OPERATION VARSITY BLUES
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS FRAUD
INVESTIGATION THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
RESPONDED BY APPROVING AN AUDIT
INTO UC ADMISSIONS PROCESS
SEES. THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND
THAT SOME UC CAMPUSES STUFF
EXPLOITED LOOPHOLES IN THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS TO OMIT
UNDER QUALIFIED STUDENTS AS
FAVORS THE STUDENTS SKEWED
WEALTHY AND WHITE. APPLICANT'S
CHANCES OF EMISSIONS WERE ALSO
FOUND TO BE OVER DEPENDENT ON
WHICH STAFF REVIEW THEIR
APPLICATION. SPECIFICALLY AB
TWO THIRTY THREE SIXTY ADDRESS
THE INHERENT IN EQUITIES OF THE
UC STUDENT ADMISSIONS PROCESS
WHICH HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
THE STATE AUDITOR. TO
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE. CAMPUS
STAFF TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
WEAKNESSES IN ADMISSIONS
PROCESS TO INAPPROPRIATELY AND
MET STUDENTS AS FAVORS TO
DONORS FAMILIES AND FRIENDS.
CAMPUS IS LOCKING KEY CRITERIA
AND STANDARDS TO SUPPORT THEIR
ADMISSIONS DECISIONS. CAMPUSES
FAILING TO ADEQUATELY ENSURE
THAT REVIEWERS AND FACULTY
CONSISTENTLY AND FAIRLY
EVALUATE APPLICATIONS. AND THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
SAFEGUARDED THE UNIVERSITY'S
ADMISSIONS PROCESS AB TWO
THIRTY THREES ALONG WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
AND REQUESTSTHE UC OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT. TO ESTABLISH
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO
IMPLEMENT A FAIR AND CONSISTENT
EMISSIONS PROCESS FOR ALL
STUDENTS CODIFYING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS SUCH AS
SUGGESTED BY THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE WILL IMPROVE
ACCESS. PROVIDE CONSISTENT
EMISSIONS KRITERIEN EACH CAMPUS
REQUIRE REGULAR INTERNAL AUDITS
ENSURE THAT EMISSIONS STAFF ARE
PROPERLY TRAINED. THIS BILL IS
NOT ONLY ABOUT THE WEALTHYAND
WELL CONNECTED INFLUENCING
EMISSIONS DECISIONS IT'S ABOUT
SOME STUDENTS BEING DENIED
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO AN
EDUCATION SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
HAD A DIFFERENT PERSON REVIEW
THE APPLICATION. ANOTHER
EQUALLY QUALIFIED STUDENT. THIS
PRACTICE WOULD NOT BE
ACCEPTABLE IN ANY INSTITUTION
LET ALONE OUR TAXPAYER
SUPPORTED PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY
IS THAT MISTER BOB HARRIS FROM
THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE. TO
SHARE THE AUDITORS FINDINGS
RECOMMENDATIONS AND TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BUT YOU MAY HAVE ON HOW
FAR THE UC HAS COME IN
IMPLEMENTING THE ORDERS
REQUEST. WHAT THE GAP IS
BETWEEN THAT AND WHERE WE NEED
TO BE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AND MISTERHARRIS WERE
VERY EXCITED J. THINK YOU ARE
FIRST TO LEAD SUPPORT OR ANYONE
WHO'S HERE IN PERSON SO WELCOME
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BOB
HARRISON WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE AND I WAS THE
PROJECT MANAGER ON A REVIEW OF
THE UNIVERSITY'S ADMISSIONS
PRACTICES- BY WAY BACK IN OUR
OFFICE DOESN'T TAKE A FORMAL.
ON BUT TODAY I'LL TELL YOU
ABOUT HOW AB TWO THIRTY THREE.
ADOPT SEVERAL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE
FOR IMPROVEMENTS WHERE WE SAW
DEFICIENCIES IN THE
UNIVERSITY'S ADMISSIONS
PRACTICES. AND HOW THE
UNIVERSITY STILL EVEN SIX
MONTHS AFTER OUR AUDIT HAS BEEN
COMPLETED HAS NOT ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS THOSE AREAS ON ITS OWN.
NOW THE BILL DOES ADOPT SEVERAL
OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS IN A
NUMBER OF AREAS I WANT TO FOCUS
ON TO IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
AND THEN TAKE QUESTIONS IF YOU
HAVE THEM. THE FIRST IS IN THE%
AREA OF APPLICANT ASSESSMENT SO
EVERY APPLICANT IS ASSESSED BY
A READER WHO REFUSE THAT
APPLICATION AND SCORES IT AND
THAT SCORE IS GENERALLY THE
BASIS FOR WHETHER SOMEONE WILL
END UP BEING COMPETITIVE FOR
ADMISSION OR NOT. SIX MONTHS
AFTER OUR REVIEW DOT WAS DONE
THE UNIVERSITY STILL NOT
IMPLEMENTED OUR RECOMMENDATION
TO HAVE TWO KEY CONTROLS IN
PLACE ONE. STANDARDS FOR HOW
THEY KNOW THAT THEIR READERS
HAVE BEEN POPERLY TRAINED WE
CALL THOSE PROFICIENCY
STANDARDS. THEY NEED TO KNOW
THAT THEIR READERS ARE. FULLY
TRAINED TO BE ABLE TO REVIEW
LIVE APPLICATIONS THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THOSE AT THE TIME OF THE
AUDIT. AND HALF OF THE CAMPUSES
THAT USE READERS STILL DIDN'T
HAVE THOSE PROFICIENCY
STANDARDS IN PLACE AS OF APRIL
OF THIS YEAR. FURTHER THEY NEED
TO HAVE ONGOING MONITORING OF
REACH READERS OF APPLICATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE APPLICATION
CYCLE TO ENSURE CONSISTENCY TO
MAKE SURE THAT. STUDENTS ARE
BEING TREATED FAIRLY. BUT NONE
OF THE CAMPUSES THAT USE
READERS AS OF APRIL HAD
ADEQUATE FULLY FLESHED OUT
MONITORING MECHANISMS IN PLACE.
AGAIN THAT SIX MONTHS AFTER WE
MET OUR RECOMMENDATION. THE
SECONDARY I WANT TO COVER FOR
YOU AND THEN TAKE QUESTIONS IS
THE AREA OF APPLICANT
SELECTION. SO ONCE APPLICATIONS
ARE REVIEWED. THE UC THEN HAS
TO MAKE TOUGH DECISIONS AMONGST
A VERY COMPETITIVE POOL OF
APPLICANTS. ABOUT WHICH-
APPLICANTS GET ADMITTED AND
WHICH ARE DENIED ADMISSION. AND
TO DO THAT FAIRLY CONSISTENTLY
AND WITH TRANSPARENCY IT REALLY
NEEDS TO HAVE DOCUMENTED
METHODOLOGIES FOR HOW IT'S
GOING TO MAKE ITS DECISIONS. WE
FOUND THE TWO CAMPUSES THE MOST
SELECTIVE CAMPUSES UC BERKELEY
AND UCLA. DIDN'T HAVE THOSE AT
THE TIME OF OUR AUDIT. AND
FURTHER IN APRIL WE FOUND SIX
OF NINE CAMPUS UNDERGRADUATE
CAMPUSES. STILL DIDN'T HAVE
CLEARLY DOCUMNTED
METHODOLOGIES. ABOUT HOW THEY
WILL MAKE ADMITTEDLY HARD
DECISIONS. TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
VERY COMPETITIVE. POOLS OF
APPLICANTS AND WITH THAT I'D
HAVE TO BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
HAVE. MISTER HARRIS IF YOU CAN
STICK AROUND THEY MAY HAVE
QUESTIONS WE GET TO THAT POINT.
WE WILL GO TO ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ALSO SEEING
NO ONE WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MAN MODERATORS OR ANYONE
WHO ON THE LINE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO THIRTY THREE. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THIRTY THREE. PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. MY NUMBER FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IMMEDIACY WOULD
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AT THE TIME I'M SURE
WE HAVE NO ONE I THINK YOU
THINK ABOUT A MODERATOR WE WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE BUT WE DO OH I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T TURN MY PHONE ACTION
SAYS NO LEAD OPPOSITION OKAY A
LEAD OPPOSITION. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
TYLER AYE YOU ARE ME HALF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEN ACCOMPANIED BY UC'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
UNDERGRADUATE ADMISSIONS ON ME
YOU AND WILL- WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB TWO
THIRTY THREE AND BEFORE ON THE
MIXER REMARKS I WANT TO MENTION
THAT YOU SEE IS ALREADY TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT ACTION IN RESPONSE
TO BOTH THE NATIONAL COLLEGE
EMISSIONS SCANDAL WHICH OF
COURSE AFFECTED COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND THE COUNTRY. AS WELL AS THE
SUBSEQUENT CSA AUDIT FINDINGS
RECOMMENDATIONS IN RESPONSE
UC'S ETHICS COMPLIANCE AND
AUDIT SERVICES BE INDEPENDENT-
INVESTIGATIVE ARM OF YOU SEE
THAT REPORTS DIRECTLY TO THE UC
BOARD OF REGENTS COMPLETED A
SYSTEM WIDE AUDIT OF UC
ADMISSION AND AS A RESULT OF
THE TO PHASE OUT IT UC CAMPUS
IMPLEMENTED EXTENSIVE CHANGES
ABOUT STRENGTHEN AND PROTECT.
THE INTEGRITY OUR MISSIONS
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES THIS
IS THIS UC PRESIDENT MICHAEL
DRAKE SEND A LETTER TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OF THE NINE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY DIRECTING THEM
TO TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTIONS IN
RESPONSE THE STATE AUDITOR'S.
RECOMMENDATIONS ON YOU SEE IT
AS AN- I THIS LETTER IS PROVIDE
THE COMMITTEE AND IS A- IN. AS
WELL. HELLO WELL INTENDED THE
CONDITIONS WHINY JERRY TWO
THIRTY THREE COULD HAVE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES FOR YOU SEE
ENCOURAGE FUTURE STUDENT BODY.
I WILL NOW ASK EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR YOON WOO TO SHARE SOME
PERSPECTIVES ON THE IMPACT OF
THIS LEGISLATION COULD HAVE ON
YOU SEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MICHIGAN WILLIAM TAYLOR IT'S
ALSO. I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST
STATE WITHOUT QUESTION THE
UNIVERSITY SHOULD HAVE A ROBUST
SYSTEM OF CONTROLS AGAINST
ATTEMPTS TO INAPPROPRIATELY
ILLEGALLY OR UNETHICALLY
INFLUENCE THE ADMISSIONS
PROCESS. ALL UC CAMPUSES HAVE
TAKEN STEPS TO STRENGTHEN AND
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF ITS
ADMISSIONS PRACTICES AND
PROCEDURES. FOR IN THEIR SYSTEM
WIDE GUIDELINES AND PROTOCOLS
FOR EACH CAMPUS IDENTIFY AND
RECORD THE RATIONALE FOR
APPLICANTS ADMITTED. THAT MIGHT
NOT MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR ELIGIBILITY OF THE LOUD BY
THE REGION'S ADMISSION BY
EXCEPTION POLICY. WE APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE'S ATTENTION TO
THIS ISSUE AND WE SHARE THE
GOAL OF ENSURING A TRANSPARENT
AND LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
EVERY APPLICANT. HOWEVER EASY
IS CONCERNED THAT EIGHTY TWO
THREE THREE COULD RESULT IN
PRACTICES THAT FAVOR A LESS
DIVERSE AND MORE SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY ADVANTAGED GROUP
OF APPLICANTS. THE COULD GAIN
THEM. GIVEN THAT THEY ARE WELL
RESOURCE. YOU SEE BELIEVES
SPECIFICITY OF. A REQUIRED
DOCUMENTS. WOULD LIKELY PROVIDE
WELL RESEARCHED FAMILIES AS
WELL AS THOSE IN THE COLLEGE
CONSULTING BUSINESS. WITH THE
SECRET FIVE HE WILL NEED TO
MARKET AND SELL THEIR SERVICES
TO GUARANTEE ADMISSION TO THE
UC LIKELY AT A VERY HIGH COST.
WHEN IN FACT THERE IS NO SUCH
FIGURES ARE. MOREOVER YOU SEE
IS CONCERNED THAT PRESSURE THIS
PRESSURE A. B. GEN THREE THREE
WORK TO BECOME LAW. WELL IN IN
BURTON WE GIVE ALL OUR
ADMISSION PROCESS INTO ONE THAT
IS FORMULA DRIVEN RATHER THAN
ONE. THAT EFFECTIVELY UTILIZE
OF COMPREHENSIVE AND HOLISTIC
REVIEW INCLUDING THE USE OF
QUALITATIVE MEASURES OF
ACHIEVEMENT. COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW IS AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK UNIQUE IN
ITS ABILITY TO ADMIT STUDENTS
BEARING CHARACTERISTICS FROM
ABROAD WHAT THE BACKGROUND. WE
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER
THE SIGNIFICANT ACTION ALREADY
TAKEN BY YOU SEE IN THE AREA OF
ADMISSIONS I THOUGHT THE
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THE FOR
LEGISLATION COULD HAVE ON YOU
SEE IF IT WERE TO BE SIGNED
INTO LAW. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW NEW MOVED
ANY LEAD OFF OR ANY OPPOSITION
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE.
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO FORTY OR
TWENTY FORTY SEEN MAN WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES MATTER MODERATED WITH
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINES WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO THIRTY THREE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY TWO
THIRTY THREE. PRESS ONE ZERO.
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE BACK
IN THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWO THIRTY THREE. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. AND AT THE TIME
ADAM HERE WE HAVE NO MONEY Q.
THANK MADAM MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU SIR VERY
MUCH- AND- APPRECIATE THE-
TESTIMONY FROM BOTH THE- AUTHOR
AND ALSO DIVERSITY CALIFORNIANS
KNOW FRANKLY I WAS FACULTY
MEMBER YOU THAT YOU SEE AND-
WHAT WAS INVOLVED IN
UNDERGRADUATE ADMISSIONS- WAS
INVOLVED IN OTHER FORMS OF
ADMISSIONS. AS WELL SO I AM
VERY SENSITIVE TO WHAT THE- UC
TESTIFIED TO YOU KNOW YOU WANT
TO TRY TO CREATE A DIVERSE
CLASS- YOU ACTUALLY. ACTUALLY
KIND OF PUT THE CLASS TOGETHER
EIGHT SO YOU DON'T EVERYONE TO
LOOK THE SAME- AS WELL BUT AT
THE SAME TIME AS A LOOK AT THIS
BILL- I DON'T SEE PROVISIONS
THAT REQUIRE YOU TO SENSE THE
USE ONE STANDARDIZED APPROACH
TO DO THIS I MEAN THEIR
STANDARDS THERE'S PIECES IN
HERE TO SAY. THAT THE FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION TO YOU SEE IS THAT-
WHY ANDERSON YEAR THE CONCERN
YOU EXPRESSED WHAT PROVISION IN
THIS BILL ARE YOU PARTICULARLY
WORRIED ABOUT THAT'S CONCRETE
ESSENTIALLY A STANDARDIZED
COOKIE CUTTER ADMISSION PROCESS
THAT WOULD ONLY ALLOW. SO I
DON'T REALLY SEE THAT IN THE
BILL- SO. IN THE ACTUAL BILL
LANGUAGE IN ORDER TO CONCERNS
SO CAN CAN YOU CLARIFY THAT FOR
ME. YES SIR THANK THEIR
PENICILLIN TYLER ARE YOU
ARRESTED IN THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA I'M ALL OUT ON THE-
YOU LOSE A SORT OF ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT. ON WHY WE FEEL THAT
THE PROVISION AND- THAT KIND OF
ACCESS TO- DOUBLES WHAT THE
METHODOLOGY IS- FOR SELECTION
OF- THAT MISSION- WHY THAT. WE
FEEL LIKE THAT COULD LEAD TO.
YOU KNOW A MORE- SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY ADVANTAGED GROUP
OF STUDENTS IT'S HARDLY WANT
TO- TAKE A STAB AT THAT. THANK
YOU SO WE FEEL THAT AND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE FEEDBACK
THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED FROM THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE THE
LEVEL OF SPECIFICITY THAT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR IS REALLY
ASKING FOR A FORMULA WHICH OUR
ADMISSION PROCESS IN USE OF
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW THERE IS
NO FORMULA CAMPUSES ARE TAKING
INTO MULTIPLE FACTORS OF
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT AND
CONTEXTUAL INFORMATION BASED ON
THEIR ACADEMIC. AND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY HAVE
HAD ACCESS TO OR NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO AND SO- YOU KNOW WE
CONTINUED TO RECEIVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT WELL HOW MUCH WEIGHT IS
GIVEN ACCESS OR HOW MUCH WEIGHT
IS GIVEN TO Y. WHEN THOSE KINDS
OF WEIGHTS ARE NEVER A WIDE THE
ENTIRE APPLICATION PORTFOLIO IS
LOOKED AT. AND THE STAFF IS
MADE FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL FOR
EVERY INDIVIDUAL SITUATION IS
VERY UNIQUE- THE DOCUMENTATION
THAT I BEING ASKED FOR
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
SELECTION METHODOLOGY. THE
OTHER THING IS THAT. OKAY SO I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW THE AUDITOR MIGHT GO
ABOUT DOING THIS PERHAPS NOW.
POSE A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
YOU'VE HEARD THE CONCERN FROM
YOU SEE- DOES YOUR BILL
ACTUALLY REQUIRES SUCH. THEY
ALL WENT WHEN IT DOES- CALL ON
ACTUALLY DOES REQUIRE YOU SEE A
P. TO STEP OF SYSTEM WIDE
PROTOCOLS. TO AND REQUIRED
CAMPUSES UNIVERSITY TAKE THE
FOLLOWING ACTIONS SO I GUESS
THAT'S FOR INTERNAL BUT PART IS
THAT THE NATURE OF THE-
METHODOLOGY CAN USE- SO HOW HOW
DETAILED METHODOLOGY ARE. YOU
INTENDING AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL- GIVEN WHAT THE-
LUCY'S CAN RAY CHARLES ARMS YES
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION THEN I'LL PASS IT OVER
THE STATE ORDER OUR INTENTION
WITH THIS IS THAT YOU HAVE A
SET OF RULES WHEN YOU GET TO
THAT COMPETITIVE SYSTEM A
COMPETITIVE POOL. THAT YOU
DECIDE IN EVERY CAMPUS CAN DO
IT DIFFERENTLY RIGHT WHAT ARE
THE THINGS THAT YOU CAN DO IT
TO THE SIDE WHO ARE YOU GONNA
DO WHO ARE YOU GOING TO MET AND
WHY WOULD HAVE LESS OBJECTIVELY
LESS. QUALIFIED STUDENT BE
OMITTED ALL WE'RE ASKING THEM
TO DO IS PUT THEIR OWN CRITERIA
WE DO THAT FOR EVERYTHING. IT'S
NOT UNREASONABLE TO ASK THAT
THE CRITERIA. ARE OBJECTIVE AND
LAID OUT AHEAD OF TIME. TO
AVOID PREFERENCES THAT HAPPEN
AND HAVE BEEN DEMONSTRATED
THROUGH THE AUDIT TO HAVE
HAPPENED. SO WITH THAT I'LL
TURN OVER TO A PODCAST- AND THE
POINTS ABOUT. HAVING A COOKIE
CUTTER APPROACH ARE WELL TAKEN
IT ISN'T THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ALREADY COVERED THE BASIC GIST
OF. OF WHY WE MADE THIS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS THAT
WHEN WE WENT TO THE CAMPUSES
THAT WE VISITED DURING THIS
ITEM WHICH WAS UCLA BERKELEY
AND SAN DIEGO. AT UCLA AND UC
BERKELEY. WHEN WE ASKED WHY
WERE APPLICANTS THAT THROUGH
THE COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW
PROCESS HAD BEEN ASSIGNED LOWER
RATINGS. ADMITTED WHEN HIGHER
RATED INDIVIDUALS HAD NOT BEEN.
UNIVERSITY COULD NOT EXPLAIN TO
US WHY. OKAY IT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE A REASON
IT'S JUST THAT THERE WAS NO
METHODOLOGY LAID OUT AHEAD OF
TIME THAT THEY COULD POINT US
TO SAY. WELL THIS IS HOW WE
WERE BUILDING OUR CLASS THIS IS
HOW WE WORK. PRIORITIZING
CERTAIN OTHER ELEMENTS OF THE
STUDENTS PROFILE TO. BUILD THE
TYPE OF CLASS WE WANTED THIS
YEAR THEY DIDN'T HAVE THAT
METHODOLOGY AND JUST TO CLARIFY
WHEN YOU SAY LOW RATED HIGH
RATED WAS AT THE UNIVERSITY'S
OWN RATING OR SEPARATING YOU
ASSIGNED THAT IS THE
UNIVERSITY'S OWN RATING GIVEN
BY ITS APPLICATION REVIEWERS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT- OKAY SO I GUESS
I'D SAY IS THAT- I THINK THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT- I'M GOING
CONVERSATION I NOTICED THE
SECOND HOUSE TO I THINK PERHAPS
SOME CLARITY ON WHAT IS MEANT
BY METHODOLOGY I AGREE WITH
THAT THE UNIVERSITY ITSELF IN
ITS OWN RIGHT NOW I'D HAVE TO
BE ALSO LITTLE CLASSES WE SAY
REVEALED THAT AGAIN I WOULD
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF THE
UNDERGRADUATE REVIEW PROCESS.
THERE IS THERE IS A ROLE IN
WHICH ANYONE SO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE INDIVIDUAL EVALUATION OF
AN INDIVIDUAL CANDIDATE AND
THEN USED SIR THINK ABOUT HOW
YOU BUILD A CLASS SOMETIMES BUT
I ALSO UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING WHEN THEY CAN'T JSTIFY
WHAT YOU NEED TO YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE EXPLAIN LIKE WHAT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS A SIDE
BILL THE CLASS WITH A CERTAIN
BALANCE AND SO WHAT WE DID IS
WE HAD A GROUP OF STUDENTS HERE
THAT SEEMED A LITTLE BIT WHAT'S
UNDER FEEL WAITED IN TERMS OF
THE CLASS DISTRIBUTION WE
LOOKED AT ALL THE THING AND SO
WE- TRIED IT MORE THE THEATER
THAT. WITH THESE
CHARACTERISTICS ETCETERA THAT-
ALTHOUGH I THINK IT'S A LITTLE
CHALLENGING ASSERTED AND THAT
SORT OF QUOTE WEIGHTED DEL- PUT
IT OUT IN ADVANCE OF THE OTHER
AND FAIRLY BROAD TERMS- BUT- I
PERHAPS THERE CAN BE SOME
ADDITIONAL WORK DONE I'M JUST
CLARIFYING WHAT YOU MEAN BY
METHODOLOGY BECAUSE I ALSO
THINK THAT IT'S ALSO DANGEROUS
TO GO DOWN A PATH WHERE YOU
KNOW WE TURN EVERYTHING INTO A
NUMBER AND THEN WE SAY WE TRY
TO BALANCE THAT OUT TOO BECAUSE
I THINK- THAT ACTUALLY GOT TO
BE DISADVANTAGES DISADVANTAGES
TO. CERTAIN TYPES OF APPLICANTS.
OPTICALLY ON. THOSE WITH FEWER
OP. SO IT'S A UP A SCHOOL IN
THE NUMBER OF EXTRACURRICULAR.
ARE TYPES OF RIGHT WE SAW BE
CAREFUL NOT DOING THAT KIND OF
THING AS WELL- BUT CERTAIN I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT-
DISCUSSION TO CONTINUE FORWARD.
HOPEFULLY PERHAPS WE CAN TRY TO.
CLARIFIED ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OF YOU SEE. ON THAT
AND SO WITH THAT CERTAINLY I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT
HOPE YOU'LL WORK WITH YOU SEE
PERHAPS JUST TO CLARIFY WHAT
YOU MEAN BY METHODOLOGY IN A
WAY THAT- DOESN'T OVERLY
RESTRICT. THE ADMISSIONS.
PROCESS BUT ALSO. AGAIN CALLED
ON ACCOUNTABILITY THAT YEAR
THAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I WILL SAYS
THE UC BERKELEY GRADUATE IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE WE WERE
TAUGHT BOTH QUANTITATIVE AND
QUALITATIVE METHODS. SO I THINK
METHODOLOGY JUST MEANS THAT
THEY HAVE A PLAN AND THEY KNOW
HOW THEY'RE BUILDING THAT
CLASS. VERSUS NECESSARILY BEING
A QUANTITATIVE FORMULA. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER CUT SENATOR
GLAZERS. THANK YOU- ON THE
FIRST DAY ASSEMBLY WOMAN NOT
BOERNER HORVATH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ENGAGED IN IN THE SPACE
AND FEWER OVERSIGHT IN THE
SPACE I MEAN CERTAINLY IT'S
THAT. THE KIND OF ISSUE THAT'S
PRICKLY AND MY COMMUNITY WHEN-
SO MANY QUALIFIED STUDENTS- HAD
SET THEIR GOAL TO ATTEND THE
UC. AND THEN- STRUGGLE AND-
WHEN THOSE RESULTS COMMAND AND
THEY WONDER WHY- ONE CLASSMATE
YES ONE CLASS RIGHT NOW I MEAN
IT'S A STRESSFUL PLACE I KNOW
IN THE LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW WE
ARE SENSITIVE TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND. UC AND CSU MORE
SO THERE'S MORE SLOTS AND
THERE'S AN EFFORT IN OUR BUDGET
PROPOSAL- THIS YEAR TO TRY TO
BUY OUT SOME OF THE OUT OF
STATE. STUDENTS SO THAT IT
COULD BE GREATER IGNITION SO I
KNOW THAT WE ALL SHARE
TOGETHER- THE IN THE GOAL OF
TRYING TO MAKE OUR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM IS ACCESSIBLE AS WE CAN
DO AS MANY CALIFORNIANS SO. ALL
THAT BEING SAID. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS I WANTED YOU
SEE TO RESPOND MORE DIRECTLY TO
THE AUDITOR'S. OBSERVATIONS
ABOUT NOT HAVING. AN APPLICANT
ASSESSMENT PROGRAM TRAINING AND
MONITORING IN PLACE NUMBER ONE.
AND NUMBER TWO. ON THIS ISSUE A
METHODOLOGY WHICH THE SENATOR
FROM SACRAMENTO HAS RAISED. IT
SEEMS THAT IN YOUR INNER CHANGE
THAT THE ISSUE IS NOT THAT IT
IS. A DISCLOSE METHODOLOGY BUT
THAT THERE IS ON THE CAMPUS OF
METHODOLOGY. THAT'S DOCUMENTED
NOT TO BE THE SECRET SAUCE THAT
GETS OUT TO- THE COLLEGE.
ADMISSIONS MACHINE THAT CAN
FAVOR FROM THE A WELL HEELED.
FAMILIES BUT I'D LIKE TO HEAR
FROM YOU SEE ON THOSE TWO
POINTS IS TO- WITH THAT THAT
THAT IS IT IS OCCURRING OR IS
NOT OCCURRING AS THE AUTHOR
SUGGESTS. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU CENTER THIS IS TYLER- YOU
HAVE TO USE THE- OFFERS TO
DRESS- THE FIRST QUESTION THAT
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT- AND I
GUESS I WOULD ASK THE HON ME TO
SORT OF TALK ABOUT. SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE- TO
STRENGTH THEN- THAT THAT FIRST
QUESTION AND THEN. IF YOU COULD
ALSO I JUST REPEAT THE SECOND
QUESTION I MY PHONE BROKE UP A
LITTLE BIT AS ONE MAKE SURE
YOU'RE CORRECTLY- SO IF YOU
COULD ON ME JUST ADDRESS THE
FIRST QUESTION ON THE- QUESTION
AND THEN THE FIRST QUESTION IS
THE APPLICANT ASSESSMENT. FOR
TRAINING AND MONITORING READER
TRAINING AND MONITORING IS THAT
NOT GOING ON. A THE AUDITOR
SUGGESTS THAT IT HASN'T BEEN
SUFFICIENT TO RESPOND TO THEIR
ISSUE. THANK YOU THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY. ANNUAL TRAINING
EVERY READER HAS TO BE.
CERTIFIED ANNUALLY THEY GO
THROUGH EXTENSIVE TRAINING
INCLUDING IN INCLUDING IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING. AND I BELIEVE
THAT IN OUR LAB. TECHNICIAN TO
THE STATE AUDITOR WE HAD
IDENTIFIED THIS IS A
RECOMMENDATION THAT WAS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED AND YET. AND THE
RESPONSE WE RECEIVED BACK WAS
THAT IT WAS ONLY PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED. SO ALSO THE TIMING
OF THE COMMISSION. WITH IN THE-
WORLD LIKE IN THE VERY CHEAP
THE ROAD OF THE ADMISSION
SEASON AND SO IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT OUR CAMPUS IS TO-
RESPOND IN A VERY THOROUGH WAY
BECAUSE- THE BUSINESS OF. IN
THERE THEY WERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE ADMISSION CYCLE. WHILE
YOU'RE PREPARING TO ANSWER THE
SECOND QUESTION LET ME JUST SEE
IF I COULD NOT INSURE ASK THE
AUDITOR TO RESPOND TO THAT THEY
SAID THEY PROVIDED AT. A
REVIEW- YOU FEEL IT WAS
INCOMPLETE CAN YOU SPEAK ANY
FURTHER ENLIGHTEN US ANY
FURTHER ABOUT THAT. YES I CAN
SO THEY DID SUBMIT
DOCUMENTATION TO US. A LITTLE
BIT THAT THEY CLAIM SUPPORTED
THAT THEY HAD ESTABLISHED. THE
PROCESSES FOR TRAINING AND
MONITORING WE DIDN'T FIND THAT
TO BE. THE CASE SO NOT AT ALL
CAMPUSES ANYWAY. SO SOME OF THE
CAMPUSES HAVE HALF OF THE
CAMPUSES THAT USE READERS. HAVE
ESTABLISHED A PROFICIENCY
STANDARD FOR THOSE READERS
MEANING A STANDARD BY WHICH
THEY NOW. THE TRAINING WORKED-
IT OFTEN WHAT WE SAW DURING THE
AUDIT WAS THAT. THE PART OF THE
TRAINING INVOLVES REVIEWING
PRACTICE APPLICATIONS AND
GIVING THEM SCORES AND GETTING.
PEER INPUT ON WHETHER WE ALL
SAW THIS SITUATION THE SAME WAY
AND SCORED IT SIMILARLY AND
WHATNOT WELL THE UC NEEDS TO
KNOW. YOU KNOW WELL WHAT IS
PROFICIENT PERFORMANCE DURING
THAT TRAINING PERIOD SUCH THAT
WE TRUST YOU TO GO OUT. AND
READ REAL LIFE APPLICATIONS WE
BELIEVE WE HAVE ADEQUATELY
TRANSFERRED. THE TRAINING
INFORMATION FROM US TO YOU THE
READERS AND NOW YOU CAN REVIEW
REAL APPLICATIONS. ONLY HALF OF
STANDARD. AND THEN NONE OF THE
CAMPUSES HAVE AN ADEQUATE
MONITORING SYSTEM IN PLACE. FOR
REVIEWING IN REAL TIME
THROUGHOUT THE APPLICATION
CYCLE TO SEE OUR READERS
DEVIATING FROM WHAT WE WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE. EACH CAMPUS
KNOWS. THE GENERAL DISTRIBUTION
OF COMPETITIVENESS THAT IT THAT
IT USUALLY GETS FROM ONE YEAR
TO THE NEXT. THERE MAY BE SOME
SLIGHT VARIATION BUT THEY KNOW
IN GENERAL APPROXIMATELY EXT
PERCENT ARE GOING TO FALL INTO
AN UNQUALIFIED OR LESS
QUALIFIED CATEGORY.
APPROXIMATELY ACTS ARE GOING TO
FALL INTO THIS AND THEN THIS IS
SIX THE GENERAL. PERCENTAGE
5210% ARE GOING TO BE THE MOST
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS. NONE OF
THE CAMPUSES OF ADEQUATE
PROCESSES IN PLACE THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE TO US
IN APRIL. FOR CHECKING IN
REGULARLY IN THE AGGREGATE ARE
WE ARE READERS GENERALLY
TRENDING. IN THESE. IN AS
EXPECTED IF THEY WARRANTED AND
THAT COULD BE A SIGN. OF A
COUPLE DIFFERENT THINGS BUT
IT'S AT LEAST AN INTERVIEW. AN
INTERVENTION POINT TO STEP IN
AND SAY. DO WE THINK THAT THIS
READERS PROBABLY NOT CALIBRATED
WELL AND NEEDS FURTHER TRAINING
IN ORDER. SUFFICIENTLY REVIEW
UP AND NOW DO NOT. THE
DOCUMENTATION IS SUFFICIENT
THANK YOU MISTER HARRIS AND I
WANNA GO BACK NOW DO YOU SEE
AND GIVE THEM ONE LAST CHANCE
THEY- THEY SAY YOU'RE NOT. ONLY
HALF HAVE- STANDARDS IN PLACE.
ON TRAINING AND THERE THERE'S
VERY LITTLE MONITORING THAT
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA CAN YOU
RESPOND AGAIN TO THAT. YOU SEE
EUROPE. THANK YOU YES THE
MONITORING ACTUALLY HAPPEN DOES
HAPPEN LIVE IN THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE MULTIPLE READERS. THE
SECOND READER DOES NOT. SEE
THE- SCORE OF THE FIRST READER.
AND THE EXPECTATION IS THAT THE
READER SCORES INDEPENDENTLY IT
WILL BE VERY SIMILAR. WHEN WE
FIND THAT THEY ARE DISSIMILAR
THEY GO T A THIRD GREEN. AND
THE CAMPUSES ARE MONITORING THE
READERS TO SEE WHY IF THERE IS
AN ABUNDANCE OF CASES WHERE I
AM. FOR THIRTEEN ARE DISCREPANT
THEN THAT DOES READERS WILL BE-
I WORKED WITH AND HAVE BEEN
HAVE BEEN RE NORMED SQL AND THE
NORMING PROCESS OCCURS
THROUGHOUT THE READING SYSTEM.
BUT THE AUDITOR CLAIMS THAT
ONLY HALF OF YOUR CAMPUS IS SET
STANDARDS IS THAT TRUE. NO I
THINK I BELIEVE ALL THE
CAMPUSES HAVE EVERY CAMPUS THAT
YOU THE READER DOES HAVE
STANDARDS. I BELIEVE THAT THE-
WHAT WITH THE MINUTE BY THOSE
TWO CAMPUSES MAY NOT HAVE MET
THE EXPECTATIONS OF WHAT THE
AUDITOR WANTED AND SO DURING
THESE PAST. SEVERAL MONTHS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
CAMPUSES IN ORDER TO- CLOSE THE
GAP. OKAY AND THEN THE SECOND
INDICATION THAT WE WILL PROVIDE
ALL RIGHT IT SOUNDS LIKE- YOU
FEEL YOU'VE MET IT BUT YOU
HAVEN'T PROVIDED THE
DOCUMENTATION TO PROVE IT TO
THE AUDITOR IS SOMETHING YOU
HOPE TO ON AN ONGOING BASIS
COMPLETE. AT THAT TO SUM IT ALL
UP THERE. OKAY YES THAT'S
CORRECT. SECOND QUESTION WAS.
ABOUT THE- DOCUMENTED
METHODOLOGY FOR APPLICANTS
SELECTION- IT SEEMS IN THE
CONVERSATION TODAY THAT. IT'S
NOT THAT THERE HAS TO BE A
COOKIE CUTTER THAT'S DISCLOSED
AND REVEALED. BUT THERE NEEDS
TO BE METHODOLOGY IN PLACE THE
AUDITOR CLAIMS THAT SIX OF THE
NINE CAMPUSES. DOES NOT HAVE
ANY METHODOLOGY ON SELECTION
AGAIN METHODOLOGY AS YOU DEFINE
SO YOU SEE CAN YOU RESPOND TO
THAT SPECIFICALLY. YOU SEE.
YEAH WE HAVE PROVIDED THE
CAMPUS ALL PROVIDED THEIR
PRINCIPLES AND VALUES ABOUT HOW
THEY SELECT THEIR APPLICANTS.
AND AGAIN THAT EXPECTATIONS-
WAS NOT FROM THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE WAS NOT MET AND YET OUR
FACULTY WHO DESIGN AND THE
POLICIES FOR THEIR LOCAL
CAMPUSES BELIEVE THAT THE LEVEL
OF SPECIFICITY THAT WAS
PROVIDED. DOES PROVIDE EIGHT
THE ADDAMS. AGAIN THE
PRINCIPLES AND THE METHODOLOGY
FOR HOW THE CAMPUSES WILL BE
SELECTING THEIR STUDENT. OKAY
AND MISTER HARRIS YOUR VIEW IS
THAT THEY THAT WHATEVER THEY
PROVIDED TO YOU DOESN'T AND SIX
OF THE NINE CAMPUSES DOESN'T
DEFINE A METHODOLOGY AS YOU SEE
IT. THAT'S CORRECT AND I WOULD
HIGHLIGHT THAT THAT MEANS THREE
OF THE CAMPUSES HAVE DONE THIS
TO OUR SATISFACTION TWO OF
THOSE. ARE VERY MATHEMATICALLY
FORMULA DRIVEN BUT ONE IS NOT
SO TO THE CONTENTION THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT. WOULD RUN
COUNTER TO WHAT THE UNIVERSITY
IS TRYING TO ACHIEVE I JUST
DON'T KNOW THAT. EVEN AT SOME
CAMPUSES. HAVE REVEALED THAT
DURING OUR AUDIT UC SAN DIEGO
HAD A METHODOLOGY THAT WE TALK
ABOUT NO REPORT THAT WE FELT
LIKE WAS. PRETTY GOOD
METHODOLOGY IT IS ACTUALLY
SINCE REGRESSED IN APRIL WHEN
WE DID OUR FOLLOW UP REVIEW
THAT METHODOLOGY HAD DEGRADED
IN DETAIL AND HAVE BEEN WATERED
DOWN TO BE LESS SPECIFIC. BUT
THERE IS STILL ONE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUS THAT'S NOT
FORMULA BASED ON THE WAY IT
MAKES ITS DECISIONS. THAT
PROVIDED US A METHODOLOGY IN
APRIL THAT WE FEEL. YOU KNOW I
MET WHAT WE WERE LOOKING FOR
WHEN WE MADE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THE UNIVERSITY CAN DO.
OKAY AND FINALLY IF I CAN
APPRECIATE THE TIME TO THE
AUTHOR- YOUR BILL SIMPLY
REQUEST AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIANS ASIAN A SENIOR AND
YOU AND I ALL I UNDERSTAND WHY
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T MANDATE- AND
THAT THAT'S THE FORM IN WHICH
YOUR BILL HAS BEEN PRESENTED.
AT IT I GUESS THE QUESTION
REALLY IS BECAUSE THIS IS LIKE
A FIGHT AMONG FRIENDS WE LOVE
OUR UNIVERSE YOU CALIFORNIA AS
EVERYBODY PERFECT NOW I MEAN
MISTAKES ARE MADE IN THEIR BIG
CAMPUSES IN THEIR ADMITTING A
LOT OF KIDS AND- IT IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A BLACK BOX WHAT'S
FRUSTRATING FOR ALL OF US- AND
WE TALKED TO FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ABOUT WHO
GETS AND WHO DOESN'T SO IT'S A
SENSITIVE POINT. IS THE REALLY
DO FEEL AT THIS POINT IN TIME
THE NEED FOR YOUR BILL IN YOUR
BILL SOMETHING REQUEST CAN WE
ARE YOU KNOW A SIX MONTH LAG
TIME TO ME IS NOT VERY MUCH
TIME TO GET THESE ISSUES
TOGETHER. I'M WONDERING IF
WE'RE JUST MOVING A LITTLE BIT
TOO FAST COULD YOU SPEAK TO
THAT SURE- I DISAGREE THAT
WE'RE MOVING TOO FAST IF YOU'LL
RECALL BACK WHEN WE DID REQUEST
THE AUDIT WE ACTUALLY TIMED OUR
STATE AUDIT. SO THAT THE UC
COULD FINISH THEIR INTERNAL
AUDIT FIRST IN THE ORDER COULD
REVIEW THAT INFORMATION BEFORE
PROCEEDING SO THE UC'S HAVE
AMPLE TIME TO FIX THE PROBLEMS
OF FAIRNESS AND THEIR
ADMISSIONS PROCESS. AND I THINK
US AS IN OUR OVERSIGHT CAPACITY
HAVE TO STEP FORWARD THE HIGH
STANDARDS THAT WE EXPECT FOR
SOME OF THE MOST WONDERFUL
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS OF HGHER
EDUCATION IN THE WORLD. AND IT
IS NOT A IT SHOULD BE WITH IN
OUR OVERSIGHT FUNCTION THAT WE
SAY THIS STANDARD HAS NOT BEEN
MET THIS IS THE STANDARD OF
EXPECTATION THAT WE HAVE FOR
BEST PRACTICES FOR FAIRNESS. I
AM A PROUD UC BERKELEY ALARM I
HAVE A GIANT CALIFORNIA MY
OFFICE IF YOU COME IN. I WANT
GENERATIONS OF CALIFORNIANS TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT SAME
PRIDE. AND IF WE DO NOT ENSURE
THE FAIRNESS IN THE ADMISSIONS
PROCESS ESPECIALLY THE TRAINING
OF THE REVIEWERS. IT'S THE
LEAST SEXY PART OF THE ENTIRE
OF. BILLS BUT IT IS THE-
BECAUSE DETERMINES. WHETHER OR
NOT THESE EQUALLY QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS HAVE A FAIR SHOT AND
ALL WE'RE ASKING THEM TO DO. IS
FOLLOW OUR OWN RULES TELL US
WHAT YOUR RULES ARE THEY CAN BE
DIFFERENT FOR EACH CAMPUS.
THAT'S NOT WE'RE NOT DICTATING
ANY OF THOSE THINGS. AND AGAIN
I WELCOME THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. TO COME BACK WITH.
WHAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE THEY
HAVE NOT REACHED OUT TO OUR
OFFICE TO OFFER MOMENTS OF
WHERE THEY CAN WORK ON THIS.
BUT I WILL OFFER AGAIN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM. YOU ALL KNOW I
ALWAYS MEET WITH EVERYBODY
HAPPY TO DO THAT. BUT I THINK
WE ARE MISSING AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE. TO REALLY ENSURE AND SET
THESE HIGH EXPECTATIONS FOR
THESE HIGH PERFORMING
INSTITUTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT AND LET ME BE
CLEAR THAT I THINK THAT THE-
THE ISSUES OF THE AUDITOR REYES
ARE LEGITIMATE ISSUES AND I
THINK THAT- THAT THEY SHOULD.
BE RESOLVED AND I GUESS THE
POINT THAT LEAVES ME A LITTLE
PERPLEXES THAT I FEEL THAT. THE
FEEDBACK FROM THE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT SEEMS TO BE
RESPONSIVE ALTHOUGH NOT
COMPLETE. AND- I WISH THAT WE
COULD GIVE THEM OF. THE TIME TO
MAKE A COMPLETE AND MAKE THIS
BILL REALLY UNNECESSARY THAT'S
THE DILEMMA FOR ME THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO TOWN I
APPRECIATE THAT. I WOULD SAY.
IF I WERE. THE PERSON MAKING
THE DECISION AND I SAW THE
STATE AUDITOR REPORT. I WOULD
IMPLEMENT THOSE THINGS AND FULL.
AN I WOULD DO IT IMMEDIATELY. A
SOME OF THE INFORMATION THAT
CAME OUT IN THE AUTUMN WAS A
GREGIS. AND THAT SHOULD NOT BE
HAPPENING AND SO I THINK WE
HAVE GIVEN THEM THE LEAD TIME
TO DO THEIR OWN ON IT FIRST
BEFORE WE WENT IN. WE'VE GIVEN
THEM A FEEDBACK OPTION TO SAY
HEY IF YOU UPDATED LET US YOU
HAVE GIVEN THEM TIME SO I DON'T
THINK GIVING THEM MORE TIME. OR
PRODUCE A BETTER OUTCOME
WITHOUT SETTING UP WHAT A CLEAR
STANDARD OF EXPECTATION IS THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU SOME THE
WOMAN- CAN WE TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES- YES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NIGHT OUT VERY GOOD WE
HAVE A MOTION. THANK YOU. THE
MOTION HAS BEEN MADE BY
SENATOR- CHOI BOGUE MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
TWO THIRTY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA
HI. LEYVA AYE OTOBO AYE BUT
TROUBLED BY COURTESY. COURTESY
I DALY. GLAZER GLAZER NOT
VOTING MCGUIRE. PAN ALL RIGHT
AND I. BELIEVE THAT BILL ON
CALL ASSEMBLY WOMAN YOU HAVE
ANOTHER BILL UP AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- MEDICARE
REACHER MEMBERS. AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN IS A COMPANION BILL TO
AB TWO THIRTY THREE. AND TAKES
THE NECESSARY COMMONSENSE STEPS
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY. IN
THE UC ADMISSIONS PROCESS.
PROTEC IN ATHLETICS EMISSIONS
WHICH ARE ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE
TO ABUSE. SPECIFICALLY AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN ENSURES THAT
DONATIONS AND PERSONAL
CONNECTIONS ARE NOT CONSIDERED
AN EMISSIONS DECISION THEY
DON'T HAVE A PLACE WHERE. WE
CHOIRS UC CAMPUSES TO REPORT ON
THEIR ATHLETIC COMMISSIONS
PROTOCOLS AND OUTCOMES TO
PREVENT FRAUD. AND REQUIRES THE
UC TO CONDUCT REGULAR INTERNAL
AUDITS OF THE ADMISSIONS
PROCESS AT UC CAMPUSES. THE
TWENTY NINETEEN VARSITY BLUES
COLLEGE EMISSIONS SCANDAL
SUBSEQUENT STATE AUDIT OF THE
UC EMISSION SYSTEM SHOW THAT
EMISSIONS FRAUD REMAINS. A
PREVALENT AND URGENT ISSUE
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. EVEN
IN THE MIDST OF A GLOBAL COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE UC
RECEIVED AN ALL TIME RECORD
HIGH NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS FOR
FALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
EMISSIONS ESTIMATED AT NEARLY
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
APPLICANTS I INTRODUCED THIS
BOTH MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE EACH ONE OF THOSE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
APPLICANTS. DESERVES A FAIR
SHOT. FOR EVERY STUDENT
ADMITTED EXCHANGE FOR DONATIONS
OR AS A FAVOR TO FRIENDS OR
FAMILY A QUALIFIED STUDENT
LOSES THEIR SPOT. UNLIKE EIGHTY
TWO THIRTY THREE WHICH TACKLES
THE OVERALL EMISSIONS PROCESS
BY REQUIRING POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES THAT ENSURE A FAIR
AND IMPARTIAL MISSIONS PROCESS.
INCLUDING TRADING FOR THE
APPLICANT APPLICATION REVIEWERS
AND READERS ON THE CONSISTENT
AND UNBIASED USE OF ADMISSIONS
CRITERIA. AB TWENTY FIFTEEN AT
TWELVE FIFTEEN REQUIRES A FIRE
WALL BETWEEN THE EMISSIONS
STUFF AT A CAMPUS IS FULL OF
THE OF PHILANTHROPY STUFF. TO
PREVENT PRESSURE TO ADMIT
STUDENTS BECAUSE OF FAMILY
CONNECTIONS I'M OF. THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES EMISSIONS STUFF
TO VERIFY STUDENT ATHLETES
ATHLETIC ABILITY OR TALENT
PRIOR. TO EMISSIONS AND FOLLOW
UP AFTER EMISSIONS TO ENSURE
STUDENT PARTICIPATION IN THAT.
SPORT VERY COMMONSENSE. ALL THE
UC STAFF THAT THE UNIVERSE
SYSTEMS TAKEN STEPS TO
IMPLEMENT THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION AS LEGISLATORS TO
ENSURE. TAXPAYER FUNDS ARE USED
AS INTENDED AND THAT DESERVING
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS ARE NOT
DISADVANTAGED BY FAMILIES WITH
MONEY AND INFLUENCE. WHAT THE
STATE AUDIT REVEALS IS THAT
MORE SIGNIFICANT REFORMS ARE
NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE WORST OF
THE ABUSES RELATIVE TO
INFLUENCING EMISSIONS
DECISIONS. AS WELL AS DEAL WITH
INCONSISTENT AND UNFAIR
ADMISSIONS PROCESS THESE
OVERALL. AB TWELVE FIFTEEN
TOGETHER WITH AB TWO THIRTY
THREE WELL INCREASE THE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO
PREVENT FRAUD AND THE UC
ADMISSIONS SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB. TWELVE FIFTEEN AND
AGAIN WE HAVE. OUR STATE
AUDITOR HERE AS ARE ARE
WITNESSING TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN MISTER HARRIS PLEASE
PROCEDURE OF TWO MORE MINUTES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AGAIN BY. STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AND AS A REMINDER OUR
OFFICE DOESN'T TAKE A POSITION
ON BILLS BUT AGAIN I'LL PROVIDE
YOU WITH AN OVERVIEW OF HOW AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN ADOPTS MANY OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE. TO
ADDRESS PROBLEMS IN THE
UNIVERSITY'S ADMISSIONS
PRACTICES AND GIVE YOU A BRIEF
UPDATE AS TO THE LACK OF
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE SEEN AT THE
UNIVERSITY CENTER ON ITS
RELEASE. A COVER THREE AREAS
VERY QUICKLY ONE IS THAT
FIREWALL BETWEEN DEVELOPMENT
OFFICE FUNDRAISING OFFICE STAFF
TALKING TO ADMISSIONS STAFF
ABOUT SPECIFIC APPLICANTS WE
SAW THAT TYPE OF COMMUNICATION
GOING ON DURING OUR AUDIT AND
SOUGHT AND JULIAN
INAPPROPRIATELY AFFECTING
ADMISSIONS DECISIONS. THE
UNIVERSITY NEEDS TO HAVE THAT
FIREWALL IN PLACE PROHIBITING
ALL COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THOSE
TWO STAFF OFFICES ABOUT ANY
APPLICANT OR PROSPECTIVE
APPLICANTS. BUT IN APRIL WHEN
WE CHECK BACK IN WITH THE
UNIVERSITY SIX OF THE NINE
CAMPUSES STILL DO NOT HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE PROHIBITION AGAINST
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THOSE
TWO OFFICES SO THAT REMAINS A
PROBLEM. SECONDLY ATHLETICS
ADMISSIONS IT'S AN AREA THAT
WAS RIPE FOR ABUSE AND THAT WE
SAW ABUSE I'VE LEADING TO
TWENTY TWO INAPPROPRIATELY
LIMITED STUDENT ATHLETES DURING
THE PERIOD WE REVIEWED. STILL
OF THE NINE CAMPUSES IN APRIL
DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE PROCESSES
ARE PLANS IN PLACE. TO FOLLOW
UP AND MONITOR STUDENT ATHLETE
PARTICIPATION IN SPORTS ONE OF
THE KEY INDICATORS OF A
POTENTIALLY PROBLEMATIC
ADMISSIONS. DECISION IS THAT
THE STUDENT ATHLETE DOESN'T
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATE IN THAT
SPORT. DO YOU SEE NEEDS TO.
TRACK THAT AND THEN FOLLOW UP
AFTER THE FACT TO CONFIRM THAT
IN FACT THERE IS NO REASON TO
BE CONCERNED OR- TAKE
APPROPRIATE ACTION AS NECESSARY
SIX OF NINE CAMPUSES IN APRIL.
STILL DIDN'T HAVE THOSE PLANS
IN PLACE AND THEN FINALLY. THE
AREA OF REGULAR ONGOING REVIEW
BY THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
AT EACH OF THE CAMPUSES TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS AS- IT'S A
KEY CONTROL THAT THEY LACK AND
THEY STILL HAVE NO ARTICULATED
PLAN. ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO CONDUCT THOSE
ONGOING REVIEWS OR THAT AGAIN
I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
HARRIS IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO WISHES
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT. FOR
AB TWELVE FIFTEEN. SEEING THEN
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE WILL NOT GO TO
LINE'S MADAME MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINES WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE FIFTEEN. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE IN THEIR OWN NOW. AT THE
TIME I'M SURE WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE
THE SAME OPPOSITION AS IN THE
FIRST BILL- WE HAVE. MS YUN WU
AND MR THANK YOU ARE SO MISTER
YOU ARE WOULD YOU LIKE TO START
AS YOU DID LAST TIME. YES THANK
YOU MANAGER I'LL BE BRIEF AS
WELL AND I'LL JUST AND ALLOW ME
TO GIVE HER REMARKS- I JUST.
WANTED TO MENTION- YOU VERY
QUICKLY THAT WE ARE ALSO
OPPOSED AB TWELVE FIFTEEN- I
DID WANT TO. MENTION THAT THE
UC IS ALREADY TAKEN SIGNIFICANT
ACTION- AND RELATE IN RELATION
TO ATHLETIC COMMISSION SPECIAL
TALENT- THERE IS A LOT LIKE
VERIFICATION. ALLOW ME TO KIND
OF GO INTO MORE DETAIL ABOUT-
THOSE ACTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN- BUT WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED AB TWELVE FIFTEEN- AND-
AND ECONOMY IF YOU WANT TO MAKE
YOUR MARKS. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU. FIRST I'D LIKE TO STATE
WITHOUT QUESTION AGAIN THAT THE
UNIVERSITY SHOULD NOT CONSIDER
AN APPLICANT'S AFFILIATION WITH
ALUMNI DONORS. STAFF FACULTY OR
OTHER EMPLOYEES OF THE
UNIVERSITY DURING THE ADMISSION
PROCESS. LONGSTANDING UC REGENT
POLICY TWENTY TWO OH TWO AND
RECENTLY REAFFIRMED THEIR
ACADEMIC SENATE RESOLUTION YOU
SEE FROM THIS LEGACY ADMISSIONS
AND DOES NOT GRANT UNTIL IT
MISSION TO THE CHILDREN OF
ALUMNI OR DONORS. ALL UC
CAMPUSES HAVE UNDERTAKEN AN
EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF WORK. TO
IMPROVE AND STRENGTHEN THE
POLICIES THAT GOVERN UC'S
ADMISSIONS PROCESS. AND ANY
GAPS IDENTIFIED WITH OUR LAST
ADMISSION TO THE- AUDITOR HAVE
BEEN CLOSED. IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION CAMPUSES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED POLICIES TO
PROHIBIT COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE DEVELOPMENT AND ADMISSIONS
OFFICERS REGARDING APPLICANTS
AND PROSPECTIVE APPLICANTS.
ATHLETIC TALENT OF RECRUIT
STUDENT ATHLETES WILL BE
VERIFIED BY AT LEAST YOU
REVIEWERS INCLUDING SOMEONE
OUTSIDE OF ATHLETICS.
ADDITIONALLY THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE ADMISSION OF A STUDENT
ATHLETE WILL BE INVESTIGATED
WHEN PARTICIPATION LAST FOR
LESS THAN. ONE YEAR AND WITHOUT
A VALID REASON. WE APPRECIATE
ALLEGE. ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE
AND WE SHARE THE GOAL OF AN
THAT. AND LEVEL FEEL FOR EVERY
CAN. YOU SEE RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREES THAT CAMPUS INITIAL
PROCESSES SHOULD BE CONSTRAINED
BY STATUTE. MOST OF THE KEY
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL HAVE
ALREADY BEEN IMPLEMENTED BY OUR
CAMPUSES. AND WE ARE CONFIDENT
THAT THE SUBSTANTIAL
IMPROVEMENTS CAMPUS MADE THAT
FAR WILL MINIMIZE THE RISK OF
ADMISSION DECISIONS BASED ON
INAPPROPRIATE INFLUENCE. WE
AFTER THE COMMITTEE CONSIDERED
THE SIGNIFICANT ACTION ALREADY
TAKEN BY YOU SEE IN THE AREA OF
ADMISSION AS WELL AS THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT THIS
LEGISLATION COULD HAVE ON YOU
SEE IF IT WERE TO BE SIGNED
INTO LAW. WE ARE FIRMLY
COMMITTED TO SAFEGUARDING THE
FAIRNESS OF ADMISSION PRACTICES
INTO MAINTAINING A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD FOR EVERY
APPLICATION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL GO TO ROOM FORTY
CHOI THREE FOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO
ONE WILL GO BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES. MATTER MODERATED TO HAVE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE HE WON
FIVE. PUSH PRESS ONE THEN THERE
ARE NOW. AND AT THIS TIME I'M
SURE WE HAVE NO ONE TO. THINK
ABOUT A MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
TO HAVE ANYONE WITH ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
CENTER CLOSER THAN SENATOR PAM.
THANK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M
LEFT A LITTLE CONFUSED AGAIN
AFTER LISTENING TO THE
TESTIMONY FROM BOTH SIDES AND I
GUESS I WOULD GO TO UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIANS SAY THE AUDITORS
MADE IT CLEAR THAT LET ME JUST
BE CLEAR THAT EVERY AREA THAT'S
BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE AUDIT
AND IN THIS BILL I SUPPORT. I
SUPPORT I THINK THESE ARE
IMPORTANT STANDARDS AND I AND-
AMBER WAS LEFT ME CONFUSED IS
THAT THE AUDITOR SAYS THAT ON
FIREWALLS SIX OF NINE CAMPUSES
DO NOT ON ATHLETICS ADMISSIONS
SIX OF NINE DO NOT- AND THAT
THERE IS AN ONGOING REVIEW BY
THE OFFICE OF THE EACH OF THE
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENTS TO ENSURE
THE STANDARDS HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWED I RECOGNIZE THE LETTER
FROM PRESIDENT DRAKE- IN
NOVEMBER THAT REQUIRES THESE
THINGS TO BE DONE BUT YOU SEE
CAN YOU PLEASE SPEAK TO. WIDE
THE AUDITOR WOULD NOT HAVE
DOCUMENTATION THAT YOU ARE IN
FULL COMPLIANCE IN THESE AREAS.
THE PRODUCT IS PROBABLY WHAT
YOU SEE I'M AN AFCON NEED TO
FIRST ADDRESS THE QUESTION
ABOUT- YES THAT WAS ONE OF THE
BEST FIREWALL BETWEEN-
DEVELOPMENT AND ADMISSIONS ON
ME. THANK YOU. SO BUT I CAN'T
IMPLEMENTED THE DEFINITION OF A
PROSPECTIVE STUDENT INFO BROAD-
A STUDENT WHO IS AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL OR MIDDLE SCHOOL IS A
PUSHED PROSPECTIVE STUDENT YOU
SEE AT SOME POINT. AND SO THE
DOCUMENTATION AND THE POLICIES
OF THE CAMPUSES HAD SUBMITTED-
pSTUDENT MIGHT BE CONSIDERED
PROSPECTIVE HOWEVER THE AUDIT-
RESPONSE. FROM THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE IT WAS TO REMOVE ALL
THAT LANGUAGE INTO FROM THE
TIME WHEN THE RESPONSE OF THE
SCENE. INTELLIGENT UP UNTIL.
LAST WEEK OR A FEW WEEKS AGO WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH CAMPUS
IS TO CLOSE THOSE GAPS AND THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE AND TO ALL THE
CAMPUS POLICIES- THAT WERE NOT.
MEETING THE EXPECTATIONS OF THE
STATE AUDITOR HAVE BEEN CLOSED
AND WE HAVE OUR OUR NEXT
SUBMISSION TO THE. STATE
AUDITOR WILL BE IN SEPTEMBER.
pTHE YOU'RE SAYING THIS IT'S GAP
THAT WITH THE AUDITOR THEY
RECEIVED IN APRIL. NOW IS OUT
OF DATE AND YOU HAVE NOT
PROVIDED THAT UPDATE YET TO
THEM. THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY THEN
I GUESS I'D GO BACK TO THE
AUTHOR THAT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OVERSIGHT IN THIS ISSUE I
AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH THE ANALYSIS FROM
THE COMMITTEE SAYS QUOTE IT
APPEARS AT THE UC HAS TAKEN
STEPS TO CORRECT THE
DEFICIENCIES- AND GOES THROUGH
THE REASONS THAT THE EXAMPLES
THAT- YOUR BILL SITES CAN YOU
SPEAK TO WHY WHY IS THIS BILL
NECESSARY WHEN IT SEEMS THAT
THINGS ARE ON A GOOD TRACK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- ENGAGEMENT
ON IT TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT IT
IS. DO WE REALLY NEED THIS BILL
SO YES WE NEED THIS BOOK IF
THEY'RE COMPLYING THERE'S NO
PROBLEM HAVING THE LEGISLATURE
SAY THIS IS OUR EXPECTATION
GOING FORWARD IN THE FUTURE THE
REALITY IS THEY'VE HAD A YEAR
AND A HALF TO DO SOMETHING THAT
LET'S JUST BE FRANK IF NOT THAT
DIFFICULT IT'S NOT THAT
DIFFICULT TO LET YOU KNOW TO
CHECK AND SEE IF THE ATHLETE
THAT SUBMITTED FOR THAT PURPOSE
IS. ACTUALLY PLAYING. THERE IS
IF YOU DON'T A YEAR AND A HALF
TO PUT THOSE POLICIES INTO
PLACE. SO THE LAGGING IN THE
LAGGING IN THE LACKING WITH
THIS. IS SHOULD BE A CONCERN TO
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US. THAT
WE'RE NOW HEARING THE ONLY
AFTER THE ORDER SAID. IT'S
INSUFFICIENT THAT THEY ACTUALLY
MOVE AGAIN. I THINK THAT ALL.
THIS ENTIRE UP AGAIN-
DISCUSSION. REALLY PROVES THE
POINT THAT WE NEED TO BE FOR
SAYING VERY CLEARLY FROM THE
LEGISLATURE SIDE. THIS IS WHAT
OUR EXPECTATIONS ARE. AND THEY
IF THEIR INTENT IS TO FOLLOW
THAT THEN THERE'S NO PROBLEM.
WITH HAVING THE LEGISLATION TO
THAT SETS OUT THE OVERSIGHT
EXPECTATIONS. GOING FORWARD AND
THAT NO MATTER WHO ELSE IS THE
PRESIDENT NO UP NO MATTER WHO
ELSE IS. THERE THE WE HAVE SAID
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE. WHAT THAT
THE SENATE SHOULD BE IN WITH
THAT ALTERNATE WITH THE AUDITOR
FOR MORE SPECIFICS. RIGHT I
CAN'T. I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHAT
THE C. MIGHT DONE AFTER WE GAVE
THEM OUR FEEDBACK IN APRIL I
CAN SAY THAT IN APRIL WITH
RESPECT TO THE FIREWALL
SPECIFICALLY. THAT GRACE PACKER
THAT PROVISIONAL PERIOD DURING
WHICH COMMUNICATIONS WERE
PROHIBITIVE WAS THREE MONTHS
BEFORE THE APPLICATION CYCLE
OPENED SO IT WAS A VERY NARROW
WINDOW OF TIME. IT DIDN'T SEEM
LIKE US THEN AND OFF TO PREVENT
SOMEBODY WHO IS SAVVY ENOUGH TO
KNOW. ABOUT THAT POLICY FROM
SKIRTING THAT POLICY BY JUST
STARTING THE CONVERSATION
BETWEEN THE DEVELOPMENT OFFICE
IN THE ADMISSIONS OFFICE. YOU
KNOW SIX MONTHS BEFORE THEIR
CHILD WOULD APPLY TO THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM SO THAT'S WHY
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT THAT
PROHIBITION BE ABSOLUTE WE
CANNOT THINK OF A TIME. WHERE
THERE IS AN APPROPRIATE TIME
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OFFICE AND
THE ADMISSIONS OFFICE TO BE
DISCUSSING. IT AT ANY POINT IN
TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS CENTER PAM.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND-
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS FROM
MY- GOOD FRIEND US ARE GLAZER-
BUT I BUT SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT PROMPT SOME QUESTIONS FOR
SOME ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS- SO
FOR THE- SIX CALIFORNIA YOU'D
MADE REFERENCE TO. THIS
DEFINITION OF PROSPECTIVE
APPLICANTS AND- I KNOW WE JUST
HEARD FROM THE AUDITOR- THIS
STATEMENT IN AN AND IT'S HARD
TO DISAGREE THAT GâY AT WHAT
POINT SHOULD DEVELOPMENT OFFICE
ACTUALLY EVER BE IN CONTACT
WITH THE ADMISSIONS OFFICE.
THAT FOR ME THAT'S FOR YOU SEE
OKAY- UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SO-
SO I AGREE YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
YOU CAN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
STUDENTS SOMEONE AS A CHILD SO
FORTH AT WHAT POINT DOES THE
DEVELOPMENT OFFICE. HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE
ADMISSIONS OFFICE DIRECTLY EVEN
IF THEY WANT TO DONATE MONEY TO
BUILD THE NEW OFFICE FOR THE
NATION'S OFFICE THAT SHOULDN'T
INVOLVE A CONVERSATION MISSIONS
OFF DIRECTLY BUT PERHAPS
ANOTHER BRANCH OF UC'S ON JUST
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHERE. IS YOU
DID YOU YOU DID SAY YOU HAD
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THAT SO I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF
YOU CAN EXPLAIN TO ME. WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THE
FUNDRAISING PEOPLE TO THEN TALK
TO THE NATION'S PEOPLE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION SENATOR
PAN. SO THERE ARE ALUMNI AND
PARENT PROGRAMS THAT WORK OUT
OF THE DEVELOPMENT OFFICE AND
OFTEN THEY ARE HOSTING- EVENTS.
IN ORDER TO BUILD A CLASS-
AFTER STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
ADMITTED PARENTS OF CURRENT
STUDENTS OR FORMER STUDENTS ARE
ADJUSTING ALONGSIDE THEMSELVES
WILL HOST AN EVENT AT THEIR
HOME IN ORDER TO- YOU KNOW
ENTICE STUDENTS TO ACCEPT THEIR
OFFERS OF ADMISSION- AND-
ALTERNATE- ARE NOT OFTEN
MENTIONED IT'S A SAFE BET. AND
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE IS
CONTACT BETWEEN THE ADMISSION
OFFICE AND THE DEVELOPMENT. I
MEAN NOT BE ABOUT A SPECIFIC
APPLICATION FOR PROSPECTIVE
APPLICANT BUT THEY'RE CERTAINLY.
REASON FOR COMMUNICATION TO A
CAR BUT NOW WE HAVE PUT THOSE
POLICIES INTO PLACE WHERE
COMMUNICATION. WILL NOT OCCUR
BETWEEN OF JONATHAN. OKAY I'M
STILL NOT SURE. AND MAYBE IT'S
A BIT OF A MOOT POINT IS SINCE%
YOU DON'T DO IT ANYMORE I'M NOT
SURE WHY THE ADMISSIONS OFFICE
STILL TALKING TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OFFICE SO. I CAN
IMAGINE DIVISIONS OUTSIDE
CONVERSATION WITH ALUMNI
OFFICE. ABOUT HEY WE WANT
ALUMNI TO HELP YA PERSUADE
APPLICANTS TO I GUESS I GUESS
AT THIS POINT GOT ADMISSION TO
ACTUALLY ACCEPT ADMISSION
RIGHTS- BUT THAT'S NOT A
FUNDRAISING FUNCTION. IS IT THE
ONLY OFFICES GENERALLY WITHIN
THE DEVELOPMENT- STRUCTURE.
OKAY WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION OF
DEVELOPMENT WELL YEAH- BRANDS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT ARE THERE
OKAY WELL AID THAT SO FIRST OF
ALL I GUESS I SHOULD BE HAPPY
TO HEAR THAT YOU DO HAVE YOU
STILL DECIDE TO HAVE A FIREWALL
BUT- I DO I DO THINK YOU KNOW
THIS YOU TALK ABOUT ETHICS AND
SO FORTH- THE PERCEPTION THAT-
THAT WOULD CONVEY THAT THERE'S
A- LAKE BETWEEN DEVELOPMENTS
AND INNOVATIONS. I THINK IT'S
ESPECIALLY A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
WOULD BE CONCERNING ONE SO- SO
HOPEFULLY AS- ONE LOOKS AT. THE
POLICY THAT YOU SEE. THAT
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO LINKED IN SOME WAY.
BUT I DON'T KNOW BUT WOULD YOU
AGREE WITH THAT. YES AN EXAMPLE.
GO HEAD TO HEAD ON THE- I JUST
WANT TO CONFIRM THAT THE CAMPUS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THAT POLICY IN
PLACE THAT ARE ALL IN PLACE
BETWEEN THOSE TWO AREAS OF THE
UNIVERSITY YEAH WELL IN%
ADDITION TO THE POLICY SO I
HOPE YOU IS- THAT THAT SOMEONE
IS IN CHARGE OF ADMISSIONS
WOULD AGREE WITH ME THAT EVEN
ETHICALLY THAT THEY'LL BE
PROBLEMATIC. AND THAT OBVIOUSLY
YOU DO HAVE SOME POLICIES IN
PLACE BECAUSE THAT IS
ADMISSIONS OFFICER AND LEADER
OF ADMISSIONS THAT YOU SEE YOU
WOULD AGREE WITH ME THAT. IN
PRINCIPLE THAT'S ALSO
PROBLEMATIC. IS THAT CORRECT.
YES ABSOLUTELY OKAY I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT- V. OKAY- AND THEN
ALL RIGHT AND THEN I DO SO YOU
KNOW- ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH- YEAH I
DID I DO. SHARE A LITTLE BIT
OF- SENATE LEADERS QUESTION
ABOUT. I GET THE FACT THAT THIS
YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY'RE TAKING
TOO LONG TO DO THINGS- BUT-
ALSO YOU KNOW- EXACTLY WHERE
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
WITH THE BILL IF THEY'RE ON THE
PATH- THE NEARLY I DON'T KNOW
WITH THAT MAKES A MOVE ANY
FASTER OR NOT- BUT I CERTAINLY
CAN ALSO HEAR YOU WE SAY IT'S
A- CLEAR DECLARATION OF THE
LEGISLATORS. LEGISLATIVE
ATTENDS- BUT THAT THAT
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR PAN CENTER CORTESE.
THANK YOU MANAGER FOR ME IS
QUESTION FOR MR HARRIS- DO YOU
DO YOU HAVE A FULL AUDIT. HERB
SCHEDULE ON THIS TOPIC OR ARE
YOU DONE. SO WE FOLLOW UP ON
ALL OF OUR AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THREE
DIFFERENT INTERVALS WITHIN THE
FIRST YEAR SO TWO MONTHS AFTER
SIX MONTHS AFTER AND THEN ON
THE ANNIVERSARY DATE THOSE AT
THE REGULAR INTERVALS AT WHICH
WE FOLLOW UP ON ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ASSESS
WHETHER THEY'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED OR NOT. THERE'S AN
ANNUAL FOLLOW UP PROCESS IF
THERE ARE STILL RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT AREN'T IMPLEMENTED WE
FOLLOW UP ANNUALLY FOR FIVE
MORE YEARS- WE ALSO DO HAVE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT
FULL BLOWN FOLLOW UP ON IT
WORK- SO THAT'S AN OPTION WE
HAVE. FOR ANY OF THE AUDITS WE
CONDUCT BUT ARE YOU GENERAL
PROCESSES TO FOLLOW UP THREE
TIMES WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR. IN
THOSE IN THOSE FOUR PARTS ARE
SHARED. WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
CORRECTED EVERY WEEK AND IF WE
SO WITH THE RECOMMENDATION
ASSESSMENTS WE POST ALL OF
THOSE PUBLICLY AND WE CERTAINLY
BE HAPPY TO. FACILITATE GETTING
ANYBODY IN THE LEGISLATURE
WHO'S INTERESTED IN- THAT
INFORMATION- SO WE POST ALL OF
OUR ASSESSMENTS OF
RECOMMENDATION STATUS TO OUR
WEBSITE. AS THE AGENCIES
SUBMIT. THEIR UPDATES TO US AND
WE REVIEW THE DOCUMENTATION.
DECIDE WHETHER WE AGREE WITH
THEIR CLAIMS ABOUT PROGRESS AND
THEN WE POST THAT PUBLICLY- AND
THEN IF WE WERE TO CONDUCT A
FULL BLOWN FOLLOW UP ON IT WE
WOULD PUBLISH A REPORT PUBLICLY
MAKE OURSELVES AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. WILL TAKE MEASURES.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT HELPS ME. TO
MAKE IT. A FINAL DECISION IN
TERMS OF WHERE I'M AT ON ON THE
BILL- I DON'T REALLY- SPENT A
LOT OF TIME ON ISSUES LIKE THIS
CONCERNING MYSELF WITH THE FACT
THAT- IN THIS CASE YOU SEE IS
ALREADY TAKEN STEPS TO CORRECT
DEFICIENCIES IN THE PROCESS
BECAUSE- IF NOTHING ELSE. YOU
KNOW THE OLD SAYING IMITATION
IS THE GREATEST FORM OF
FLATTERY IS HOW THEY SHOULD
HOLD THIS I THINK AS AFFIRMING.
OF THE STEPS THEY'VE ALREADY
TAKEN IF THEY FEEL THAT THERE.
ARE TWO PROTECTIVE IN ANY WAY-
BUT I THINK THAT SHOULD BE
TAKEN AS- IS AFFIRMATION THAT
THE- THE DOING THE RIGHT THING
BUT ALSO A CODIFICATION. OF
WHAT THE EXPECTATIONS ARE GOING
TO BE IN THE FUTURE- IN A
CODIFICATION OF A THINKCENTRE
BENCHMARK AS THE AUDITOR COMES
BACK. TO CHECK AND MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE POLICIES HAVE- HAVE
THAT STAYED IN PLACE AND ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK. ALBEIT THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MANDATE ON ON THE
CONASAUGA STATION TO DO
SOMETHING BUT THIS LEGISLATURE
COULD FALL UPON THOSE AUDITS
SERVE WITH LEGISLATIVE
HEARINGS- IF HE AND OTHER
METHODS. TO DRAW ANY CONTINUING
PROBLEM AND I THINK AT THAT
POINT BUT IT WILL BE A LOT
EASIER. AGAIN THE BENCHMARK
THOSE HEARINGS AS AS TO WHAT
THE EXPECTATIONS ARE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY ACTED
AND SAID THIS IS WHAT THE
EXPECTATIONS ARE GOING TO BE A
IN THE EVENT THE LEGISLATURE
COMES BACK AND TAKES ANOTHER
LOOK AT THIS AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT HE BE TWELVE FIFTEEN
BECAUSE AND- I APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS IN THAT REGARD I'M
SPEAKING TO THE AUTHOR AT THIS
POINT SO. I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL IN THANK
YOU MANAGER THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I DO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE BILL. THANK VERY MUCH
CENTER. SAID A SOME CHOI TO
CLOSE. YES I THINK I'LL TAKE
SENATOR CORTESE'S. LAST FINAL
COMMENTS AS MY CLOTHES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE VERY GOOD THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND I JUST
TO WANT TO ADD MY APPRECIATION
FOR YOU BRING BOTH OF THESE
BILLS FORWARD I THINK THAT- AS
YOU STATED. SEVERAL TIMES.
THERE ARE NOT THAT HARD TO DO
AND NOT THAT HARD TO VERIFY
THESE THINGS AND WE WANT EQUITY
FOR EVERYONE. WHO WANTS TO GO
TO UC SO WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTESE.
MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE A. B. TWELVE FIFTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA
AYE. LEYVA AYE OCHO ABOVE. A
TROUBLED AYE CORTESE AYE AS THE
AYE DELI. DELHI BY GLAZER.
GLAZER NOT VOTING MCGUIRE PAN.
AM HI. WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL
ON CALL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE. GIVE
THURSDAY SNEEZE AB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE
ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS SERVING
STUDENTS IN GRADES SIX THROUGH
TWELVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITIES AND CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DISTRICT TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH ACCESS TO
PREMENSTRUAL PRODUCTS I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR QUITE
A WHILE. MY MOM STARTED HEARING
ABOUT MY PERIOD. BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT THIS DOES
BECOME A VERY A FOR SOME
INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE ARE NOT
JUST A YEAR OF MEANS ARE NOT
OUR BIOLOGY DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK
WITH THAT IS THAT IT'S NOT
ALWAYS PLANNED. A AND OFTEN
TEND TO TAKE A LOT OF TIME
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DEAL WITH THEIR PERIODS AND SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
THIS HAPPENED STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE HALF AN HOUR TO GO
TRACK DOWN A MISTER PRODUCT OR
HAVE TO USE- NEWSPAPER
SUBSYSTEM OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
DISMISSED AT COMPLETELY ON
CLASS AND SO. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I'LL
LET MY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
FILL IN THE REST OF THE HOLES
ON THE- THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIRELESS EFFORTS ON THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE IT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR LEAD SUPPORT
WHICH IS CATHERINE SUE AND
AMANDA SAFETY. OF BOTH OF YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES WHO IS GOING
TO START. I WILL START THIS IS
CALCULATED. PLEASE PROCEED-
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CALVIN SHOE
NUMBER RIGHT HERE I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL NEXT YEAR ABOUT A
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. I
WOULD LOVE TO HELP REFILL OF
COUNCILS OF THE POLICY DIRECTOR
AND CAST WITH THE PROUD TO
SPONSOR. OF AB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN. HERE'S SOME BACKGROUND
BY IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AB HAS
PASSED. WHICH REQUIRED ALL ONE
SCHOOLS PROVIDE PRETTY MUCH OF
PRODUCTS IN OTHER STUDENTS.
OTHER SCHOOLS. THE DAILY NEWS
AS GREAT AS BILL WAS IT DIDN'T
COVER POPULAR. AND TO DIDN'T
HAND A ONE SCHOOLS WERE HELD
FOR THE 25% OF STUDENTS WHO
LIVE BELOW THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LINE. NO ATTENDED HOW TO ONE
SCHOOL. IT ALSO DOESN'T
INDIVIDUALS AND COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. I DEMONSTRATED
THERE ARE VERY MANY TIMES AT%
SCHOOL WERE AND HOW DESTRUCTIVE
TO MY LEARNING FROM HAVING TO
GO HOME DUE TO LACK OF DIRECT
ACCESSIBILITY TO NATURAL
PRODUCTS. NOT ONLY HAVE I HAD
THESE EXPERIENCES SO MANY OF MY
PEERS HAVE ALSO HOW TO MAKE
MAKE SURE IT'S NATURAL PRODUCTS
OUT OF TWELVE PEOPLE IN
SCHOOLS. THIS SHOULD BE THE
CASE AFTER THREE MONTHS OF
COLLEAGUES IN THE BASIC NEEDS
IT SHOULD BE A HUMAN RIGHT AND
IT'S TIME THAT WE START MAKING
IT ONE OF THE READING. PRETTY
MUCH A PART OF THE COUNTRY. BUT
WE HAVE TO BRING A THIS ISSUE
TO MY SCHOOL. THEY QUICKLY TOOK
A- TO PROVIDE YOU MARKETING
SIMPLE. AND ALL PEOPLE ABOUT.
IN ALL ALL CHEN BATHROOMS. I
WOULD PROBABLY SUGGEST THAT ANY
FOR CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST OTHERS
WELL. EVERYBODY LIKE ACCESS TO
HEALTH INSURANCE YOU DON'T HAVE
A MORE EQUAL ACCESS TO
EDUCATION AND ARE IN HARD TO
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
THEIR RESPECTIVE OF THEIR
GENDER OR ECONOMIC STATUS. THE
CRITICAL SEVEN ENSURING THAT WE
FEEL COMFORTABLE AND SAFE AND
OUR BODIES AT SCHOOL AND IN
ENSURING WHAT WE HAVE A PLACE
WHERE WE ARE ABLE TO.
COMFORTABLY THANK YOU SO IN
MEMBERS VEHICLE EMPOWER OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THE CONVERSATION. I THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME AND
STRONGLY URGE YOUR I DON'T WANT
YOU TO SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING SHERRY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMANDA SAKE
AND I AM A SECOND YEAR STUDENT
AT UC SANTA CRUZ AND I AM A
CROWD EQUITY ACTIVIST IN MY
WORK THIS PAST YEAR
SPEARHEADING THE PROJECT IN
CHEN THE KING COUNTY I'VE HAD A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS WITH
FRIENDS AND CLASSMATES ABOUT
OUR STRUGGLE WITH ACTIONS TO
PERIOD PRODUCTS AT SCHOOL. AND
I WANT TO SHARE ONE OF THEIR
STORIES TODAY. MY FRIEND GOT
HER PERIOD RIGHT BEFORE SHE HAD
TO TAKE A PHYSICS TEST SHE
AFTER TEACHER TO USE THE
BATHROOM AND THEN REALIZED THAT
SHE DIDN'T HAVE ANY PADS OR
TAMPONS SO SHE WENT BACK TO
CLASS AND SHOT UNCOMFORTABLY AT
HER DESK UNABLE TO CONCENTRATE
ON HER CHEST WHILE SHE BLED
THROUGH HER PANTS. AFTER THE
BELL RANG SHE HAD TO LEAVE
CAMPUS TO CHANGE HER
BLOODSTAINED PANTS AT HOME WHEN
HER MOM CALLED THE OFFICE TO
EXPLAIN HER LEAVING SCHOOL
OFFICE MARCH MY FRIENDS OPTIONS
AS A CUT INSTEAD OF EXCUSING IT
AS AN EMERGENCY. EVERY TIME I
WOULD HEAR ONE OF THE STORIES
MY HEART WOULD ACHE BECAUSE IT
USUALLY RESULTED AND
ADMINISTRATOR BEING FORCED TO
USE AND PLANETARY MEAN MISSING
EXCESSIVE CLASS TIME OR
PRACTICE OR LEAVING SCHOOL
ENTIRELY. MENSTRUATE IS LIKE
EASE AND MYSELF LIVE AND
BREATHE THAT STIGMA EVERY DAY
THAT WE STEP INTO A PUBLIC
BATHROOM THAT DOES NOT. HAVE
FREE PERIOD PRODUCTS. WE SHOULD
BE STOCK ABOUT THE A THREE
PRODUCTS AND WAY THE WE STILL
THEM WITH BETWEEN THE EIGHT
BURKE. IF DURING A- IT SHOULD
BE PART OF CULTURE AND- OF OUR
SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC FACILITIES.
BECAUSE MENSTRUATION IS A
NORMAL AND NECESSARY PART OF
OUR BIOLOGY. LOADING I ON AB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN TRYING TO
MESSAGE TO NOT ONLY MENSTRUATE
EARS BUT ALSO OTHER STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT
MENSTRUATING MATTER. BOATING I
ON AB THREE SIXTY SEVEN WOULD
ALSO MAKE CALIFORNIA A LEADING
STATE IN FIGHTING POVERTY IN
AMERICA. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. ABOUT ONE EIGHTY
THREE FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOOD
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE FOR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO
ONE HERE WILL GOING TO GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO ONE
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MATT I'M A MODERATOR TO HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. AB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF AB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ONLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. ONE NUMBER FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THINK YOU CAN AND
THAT IN TURN MEMBERS KAREN
LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF CONFERENCES GO
AND THE SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CANNOT THE VAN AUSTIN
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE SEVEN. BY NUMBER FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MA'AM SURE
MEMBERS RYAN SPENCER ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN SCHNEIDER IN SUPPORT. BY
NUMBER SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BY NUMBER FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MONEY
MANAGER AND MEMBERS WILLIAM
BURKE ON BEHALF OF NAY RAP
SEARCH WITH CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES THAT
PATIENT IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS SENT TO BROWN
BOTH SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EDUCATORS THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. BLIND NUMBER
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
HANNAH BAGHDAD WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE NUMBER
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DIMITRIUS THE
WORD NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING MY
NAME IS JASIM PRASAD ON BEHALF
OF THIS INCIDENT FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO
EIGHT SIX SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BILLY
PRESSURES AND ON BEHALF OF
COLFAX CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTY SEVEN.
BY NUMBER THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
JASON SOME I DON'T FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM SO STATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER FIFTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORE LIKELY THAN NOT
AFTER ALL. WELCOME BACK. WELL
WHAT. AND AT THIS TIME AND I'M
SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR WE
WILL NOW TO GO TO ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE A ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE WHO WANT
WISHES TO OPPOSE SEEING NONE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN NONE
MATAMATA RAIDERS ANYBODY ON THE
LINE WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE AB
EIGHT. EXCUSE ME THREE SIXTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF
AB THREE SIXTY SEVEN QUID PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
SIXTY SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. AT THE TIME
AND I'M SURE WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. KAMALA MODERATOR WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- CINNAMON. ACT THANKS
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS
YOU'VE STATED HOPEFULLY ITSELF
OF AND EVERYONE AS A PHYSICIAN.
ST STEP WHAT SELF EVIDENT IS
THAT MINISTRATIONS IN NORMAL
PHYSIOLOGIC PROCESS AND EVEN
ONE THAT SOMEWHAT-
UNPREDICTABLE AND- AS WELL SO
NOT HAVING THESE PRODUCTS IS-
IS A TERRIBLE PROBLEM- AND SO
WITH THAT AND I. MOVED TO BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER PAN
ANY. OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU AND THE PEOPLE IN SUPPORT
AND- YOU KNOW I AM I WILL BE
CARRYING OF BILLS IN THE SPACE
UNTIL THIS IS ACCESSIBLE LIKE
TOILET PAPER. EVERYWHERE AND SO
I ENCOURAGE FOLKS LISTENING
THAT THEY'D ONLY FOR A BILL TO
BE INTRODUCED TO THE HAVE A-
FACILITY THAT THEY FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN IT'S
PRETTY EASY YEAH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PAN. MEDIC CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA AYE. LEYVA AYE
OTOBO AYE BUT TROUBLED BY
COURTESY. COURTESY I DALY
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE. PAN
HI AN HIGH. THAT BILLS OUT BUT
WE WILL THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
HAVE A GREAT REST TODAY. ALL
RIGHT WE ARE ON TO OUR LAST
BILL THE DAY THAT IS FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB NINE FORTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- I RISE TODAY TO.
PRESENT AB NINE FOUR FIVE TO
HELP ENSURE THE NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS MAY EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHT TO WEAR ITEMS OF
SPIRITUAL OR CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE GRADUATION
CEREMONIES. AB NINE FOUR FIVE
ESTABLISHES A TEN MEMBER TASK
FORCE OF CALIFORNIAN NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBAL MEMBERS AN
APPOINTEE FROM THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION. THIS TASK FORCE
WILL BE CHARGED WITH GATHERING
INFORMATION ABOUT NON
COMPLIANCE WITH THIS PROTECT IT
RIGHT AND WHAT CAN BE DONE TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE IT WOULD ALSO
BE CHARGED WITH RECOMMENDING
BEST PRACTICES TO EIGHT SCHOOL
AUTHORITIES IN ENSURING THE
EXISTING PROTECTIONS OF
STUDENTS. RIGHT TO WEAR
TRADITIONAL TRIBAL REGALIA OUR
RECOGNIZE OBJECTS OF RELIGIOUS
OR CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE AS AN
ADORNMENT AT SCHOOL GRADUATION
CEREMONIES. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN MY GOOD FRIEND TODD
GLORIA WHO'S NOW THE MAYOR OF
SAN DIEGO MOVED FORWARD ON A
BILL BUT STILL WE SEE
THROUGHOUT THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM THAT THERE'S NOT PARITY
AND ALLOWING STUDENTS TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND
SHOW PRIDE. IN THE REGALIA- OF
NATIVE AMERICAN- AREAS
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WHO IDENTIFY AS
NATIVE AMERICANS REPRESENTING
THE LARGEST STATEWIDE
POPULATION OF NATIVE AMERICANS
IN THE UNITED STATES. NATIVE
AMERICAN GRADUATES WANT TO
DEMONSTRATE PRIDE IN THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS TO THEIR FAMILY
INTO THE TRIBE THAT THAT THEY
REPRESENT. CULTURAL ITEMS OFTEN
ARE GIFTED TO THOSE OF
SOMETHING OF ACHIEVEMENT AND
SOMEONE SOMEONE IS GRADUATING
FROM SCHOOL THEY MADE THAT MARK
IN IN THE INDIAN COMMUNITY THIS
STILL IS THAT PARITY OF THOSE-
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL
THAT'S STILL FAR BELOW THOSE
OTHER GROUPS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO WHEN THEY HAVE A
MEAL AND THEY GO THEY'RE GIFTED
THINGS OF EAGLE FEATHERS OF
DIFFERENT REGALIA IT'S A PRIDE
FOR THE FAMILY FOR THEM TO WEAR
AND WALK A CROSS THAT'S- TO
EARN THEIR DIPLOMA. THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT THAT PRIDE THAT
SUCCESS IS NOT DETERRED BY ANY
POLICY THAT'S OUT THERE IS
SPECIALLY WHEN IT'S ALREADY
LAW. THIS BILL WOULD START TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT RIGHT IS
EXERCISED THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT
OUR ACADEMIC. INSTITUTIONS
TODAY YOU'LL HEAR FROM TEDDY
SIMON FROM THE INDIGENOUS
JUSTICE INTERIM PROGRAM AND
RAIN MARSHALL FROM THE
NDIGENOUS EDUCATION I'M
ADVOCATE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE FOUR FIVE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE WILL NOW GO
TO OUR LEAD SUPPORT MISTER
TERRY SIMON AND MR MARSHALL I
WILL LET YOU DECIDE WHO GOES
FIRST YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
PLEASE PROCEED. HEY EVERYBODY
SICK THAT IS- EVAN I DON'T
EXPLAIN IT AND I AM SURE IF I
HAD ELECTION I THINK TWENTY
FIVE MAN UNITS YET- GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS. SIMON I'M
THE INDIGENOUS JUSTICE ADVOCATE
AT THE ACLU OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I THOUGHT THAT
PUBLIC LANDS. PLEASURE TO
ADDRESS- DUSTIN EDUCATION
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING THE
RIGHT TO WEAR TRIBAL REGALIA
AND OTHER OBJECTS ON RELIGIOUS
OR CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE THAT
GRADUATION IS PROTECTED UNDER
THE U. S. THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. AS WELL AS BY
EDUCATION CODE SECTION THREE
FIVE ONE EIGHT THREE POINT ONE
BUT DESPITE THE CLEAR
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS
DISTRICTS CONTINUE TO ATTACK
TEMPOS RESTRICTIONS THE
INTERFERE WITH STUDENTS RIGHT
TO WEAR TRIBAL REGALIA. AND
RECENTLY AT THE SPRING OF
TWENTY TWENTY REVIEW THE
COMPLAINT FROM A TRIBAL MEMBER
STUDENT WHO INSTALLED HE WAS
NOT ALLOWED TO WEAR AN EAGLE
FEATHER. ON HIS GRADUATION CAP.
ALL THE STATE CALIFORNIA NEEDED
MY STUDENTS BASED THE QUESTION
WORSE OUTCOMES THE KEEP YOUR
TROPICAL THE TIME. FROM COAL
PUSH OUT THE CREDIT CARD HE IS
ON TO COLLEGE AND CAREER. THE
PUBLIC. SYSTEM BEEN YOU AS A
TWO OF JENNIFER IN CULTURE
RACIAL THAT A CAR. COOPER TO
FIND A RAY. AT THE- WE NOW HAVE
A GREAT IT FOR TO BE ABLE TO
WEAR. THESE ITEMS HAVE TROUBLE
REGALIA GRADUATION IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT RITE OF PASSAGE FOR
STUDENTS AND AN IMPORTANT
MOMENT THEIR PMI. WEARING A
THREE GARY A LOT TO HONOR THEIR
TRADITIONAL CULTURE AND A LOT
OF THE ENTIRE TO COMMUNITY TO
REALLY BE THEIR CULTURE
REFLECTED IN THAT THE WELFARE.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE DIFFICULTY
THERE AND IT WAS DISTRICTS
RESTRICTING THE RIGHT TO WEAR
TELERIK IDEA OUT GRADUATION
DESPITE THE CLEAR
CONSTITUTIONAL LEGAL
PROTECTION. I'M AT LEAST
PROPOSED THE TASK FORCE TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT IS HAPPENING
AND TO DEVELOP SOLUTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS RIGHT
ARE PROTECTED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU GET THE EMAIL CHAPPIE
MEHAJER NOT TAKING THE- TIME TO
A WASH DAY NOT PAY TO USE IP.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS RAY
MARSHALL AND THE INDIGENOUS
EDUCATION ADVOCATE WITH
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA INDIAN
DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL. A
NONPROFIT IN CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S A COLLABORATION WITH THE
ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO A MOTHER OF TWO
DAUGHTERS. THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM. MY YOUNGEST
DAUGHTER JUST GRADUATED THIS
YEAR. AND BOTH SUPPORT TRIBAL
REGALIA THE CONGRATULATIONS
CARE MONIES INCLUDING EAGLE
FEATHERS AND BEADWORK. ON THEIR
GRADUATION CAP. I ALSO
GRADUATED FROM THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL CALIFORNIA AND I WORK IN
EAGLE FEATHER. AND BEAD WORK AT
MY HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION.
LOCALLY IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
A LOT OF THE LOCAL INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE HAVE. BASKET CAPITAL
BEEN PASSED ON IN THEIR FAMILY
FOR GENERATIONS THESE ARE ITEMS
OF CULTURAL AND RELIGIOUS
SIGNIFICANCE. THAT NEED TO BE
HONORED. IN OUR TRADITIONS
MASAKO TIME THAT WE PRAY WITH
EAGLE FEATHERS I RECEIVED MY
FIRST EAGLE FEATHER AT AGE
TWELVE AND THEN AGAIN WHEN I
GOT A NAMING CEREMONY MY TWO
DAUGHTERS ALSO HAVE HAD MEANING
CEREMONIES WHEN THEY RECEIVED
EAGLE FEATHERS- SOME OF MY
EARLIEST MEMORIES ARE. KNOWING
HOW TO TAKE CARE OF MY REGALIA
AND MY EAGLE FEATHERS IN TERMS
OF WRAPPING THEM AND KEEPING
THEM PROTECTED THEIR SACRED
ITEMS. THEY SHOULD BE PROTECTED
THEY'RE ALREADY PROTECTED-
STUDENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
UNDER THE FIRST AMENDMENT FOR
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION ALREADY
PROTECTED UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION CODE. THEY ARE ITEMS
THAT ARE SIGNIFICANT LIFE
EVENTS THAT ARE. DESIGNED TO
SHOW HONOR HONOR NOT ONLY FOR
THE EAGLE. AS THE SYMBOL OF
TAKING A PRAYER TO THE CREATOR
BUT ALSO AT THE SIGNIFICANT.
LIFE EVENT FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
WHO RECEIVED THEM. BUT THE
HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA AND ALL
OF THE UNITED STATES THE FORCE
TO SIMULATION THE IN THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IN BOARDING
SCHOOLS THANK THE LOSS OF LIFE
THE TORTURE AND MALTREATMENT.%
IT'S ALL THE MORE REASON TO
PASS THIS BILL TO RESERVE THE
RIGHT THAT INDIGENOUS PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE TO EXPRESS
THEIR IDENTITY AND CULTURAL
PRIDE. ESPECIALLY GIVEN LIKE
THE GOVERNOR HAS CREATED THE
TRUTH AND HEALING COUNSEL. I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OKLAHOMA PAKISTAN. THE YOU VERY
MUCH TO ME WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE WE
WILL GO TO PHONE LINES MADE A
MODERATOR TO HAVE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE FORTY
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER IN
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF AB. NINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. BY
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE STREET ON
BEHALF OF BOTH THE COLUSA AS A
CHILD THE TRIED- CAL WITH A
SPONSOR TO GLORIA FAIL. THANK
CHAIRMAN RAMOSE AND- CAN I VOTE
AND CO SPONSORS THE POSSIBLE IT
NEEDS TO SEND A MESSAGE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANELA LOPEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE TRULY
RIVERSIDE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANOTHER TIME MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM MODERATOR
WE HAVE NO ONE ARE LISTED AS
LEAD OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
WOULD WHO WHICH IS TO OPPOSE
THE BILL SEEING NONE OF THE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES BETTER MODERATED WE HAVE
ANYONE WHO WISHES. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY NINE FORTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. NINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO THEIR OWN NOW. AND
AT THIS TIME ADAM HERE WE HAVE
NO ONE Q. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR FOR GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS. THE BILL. ALL RIGHT
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DOLLY- OKAY MONTHS
ANYBODY ELSE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU AS RELY VOTES IN ANY
CO AUTHORS THAT WOULD BE
WILLING TO ADD ON TO THIS BILL.
SOUNDS GOOD CENTER GLAZER. I'D
LIKE TO MAKE. THANK YOU. I AS
WELL THANK YOU AND CENTER DOLLY
YOU KNOW ADD ME TOO IT'S A
GREAT BILL. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR DOLLY MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE NUMBER SEVEN A. B. NINE
FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
LEYVA. BY LEYVA AYE OTOBO AYE A
TROUBLED AYE COURTESY AYE
COURTESY AYE DELI. DELI I
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PANTS
HI AN HIGH. NEWLY THE ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THAT THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SOME OVER
ALMOST HAVE A GREAT REST OF THE
DAY. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO LIFT CALLS. PUTS ON
START WITH IF YOU VOTED ON
EVERYTHING HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENDANCE THIS MORNING- LET'S
START WITH THE- CONSENT
CALENDAR NO. I FELT VERY GOOD
SO THE ONLY PERSON WE NEED A
SENATOR MCGUIRE SENATOR MCGUIRE
FOR OUT THERE COME ON DOWN.
OKAY LET'S CALL THE ROLL ON THE
BILL'S IT ON CENTER DOLLING
THIS REPORT ON PLEASE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B. NINETY
TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
CHAIR VOTING NINE VICE CHAIR
VOTING ONLINE DAILY. DALY NOT
VOTING MCGUIRE. WITH. SIX ZERO
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
SENATOR MCGUIRE NEXT BILL
PLEASE ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B.
TWO THIRTY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE CHAIR VOTING ONLINE
DELHI DELHI I MCGUIRE. LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR CENTER MCGUIRE.
ADAM NUMBER FIVE AB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE RE REFER RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING ON A DAILY. DALY NOT
VOTING MCGUIRE. WE WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL AS WELL. THANK YOU
SENATORS HAVE A GOOD REST OF
THE DAY. MOST WELCOME.
THE TERM
ACQUIRES HERE LET'S LIFT THE
CALL ON ALL BILL STARTING WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE IN
CENTER VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING ONLINE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE THE BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B. NINETY
TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE YOU'RE
VOTING AYE DELI DELI NOT VOTING
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE THAT BILLS
OUT SIX ZERO. ADAM NUMBER TWO
AB TWO THIRTY THREE.THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING
NINE FIVE SURE VOTING AYE.
GLAZER GLAZER NOT VOTING
MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE I. THE BILL'S
OUT SIX ZERO. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE A. B. TWELVE FIFTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING
NINE VICE CHAIR VOTING ONLINE.
GLAZER CLOSER NOT VOTING
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE THE BILLS
OUT SIX ZERO. FILE NUMBER FIVE
A. B. THREE SIXTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING ON A- DELHI DELHI NOT
VOTING MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
THAT BILLS OUT SIX ZERO. FILE
NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY NINE FORTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. CHIU
FORTY NINE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE I SAID
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YOU'RE VERY WELCOME
SIR THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU FOR TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION IS ADJOURNED.
WE'RE SORRY YOUR CONFERENCE IS
ENDING NOW PLEASE HANG UP.